der
So, ich hab jetzt hier Tee und Wasser und bei Wasser muss ich auch füllen, ich muss
hier Hydrated Stain im Streamen.
Achja, der Titel ist heut Programm, ich hatte keine Ahnung was ich sonst streamen kann und
ich muss ein paar Dinger zusammenlöten, nichts grossartiges, es sind im Prinzip zum größten
Teil irgendwelche Hedder Pins dran, hab ich gedacht wir können das einfach im Stream machen
und bisschen dabei schwätzen.
Why not?
So, jetzt muss ich erstmal mein komisches, übrig gebliebenes DX Racer Kissen, dem ich
keine DX Racer Stühle mehr hab, aber das Kissen ist übrig, wird aber ordentlich platzieren,
deswegen nehme ich gerade am Poppes unten, weil es runter gerutscht ist, das war nicht
so bequem.
So, ja, warten wir erstmal bis Twitch erkannt hat, dass der Stream online ist, Pepo Fett,
ja, ich hab Pepo abnehmen gemacht die letzten zwei Monate, einen Monat, ein Monat, eineinhalb
Monate.
Ostchamp, guck mal Finger League, Finger League, Finger League, Finger League, Finger League,
hier übrigens Finger League, ne, die Katze hat mich an einer richtig beschissenen Stelle
gekratzt, ich weiß nicht ob man das erkennt, warte mal, ich mach mal kurz, kurz groß, mal
kurz das weg, das ist übrigens kein Staub da unten, das ist gebohrt aus, aus, also
mit dem, wie heißt es richtig, Stufenbohrer, nicht Kegelbohrer, das hat mir letztens der
Chat erklärt, aus so einem Gehäuse rausgebohrt, guck mal, die Katze hat mich heute richtig,
richtig doof gekratzt aus Versehen, seht ihr das, das tut nicht, das tut nicht weh großartig
oder so, aber das ist genau da am Finger wo man es merkt, guck mal, das ist genau, das
ist genau hier, naja nicht so exzellent, guck das ist genau hier und das ist übelst nervig,
weil es halt auch genau da ist wo man die Tastatur für braucht und so, naja, ja Chico
hat wieder zugeschlagen, Rache für was, die Katze hat das beste Leben bei mir, es gibt
nix wofür man sich rechnen müsste, Alter, Orgurs, Lötke, so siehts aus, Lötke, Tür
nicht aufgelassen, Lötke, Tortilla Chips, Moin, Chat in der VM, oh stimmt, Moment, Moment
Leute, oh jetzt geht er, das geht ja nicht Leute, das geht ja nicht, Better Twitch TV,
was ist da los, zu Firefox hinzufügen, auf gehts, Add, jaja ok, was, Permissions, was,
YouTube, who cares, YouTube, ok Chat, testet mal, testet mal, Emotes, gehen die Emotes
jetzt im Chat, mein FFZ sollte jetzt an sein, ja geht, Giga Chat ist am Start, Agrege, alles
gut, nice, jetzt haben wir auch, jetzt haben wir hier auch ordentliche Emotes, so muss
das sein, Amiris, das kennt überhaupt keiner mehr, die ganzen, die ganzen Post Modern Warfare
Kids, die denken, dass Modern Warfare 2022 das richtig echte Modern Warfare 2 ist, die
haben gar kein Plan, ja wie gesagt Leute, also es ist heute nix großartiges, ich sitz
hier, löte ein paar Pins dran und ihr könnt alle möglichen Sachen in Chat posten und ich
sag dann was zu, also im Großen und Ganzen, was wir machen müssen, ich zeigs mal kurz,
wie gesagt, das ist nicht so super spannend heute, also was wir machen müssen, mal kurz
mal hier den großen Kolben, machen wir mal weg, so ich hab noch ein paar, ich hab noch
drei ESP32 D1 Mini, die brauchen Pins, wobei ich glaube ein ohne Pins lasse, also das,
das müssen wir machen, also das ist nix, einfach die Pins dran, einen lasse ich glaube ich
auch mal ohne Pins, so, Alter was mit der Musik los, nicht übertreiben, das ist nicht
so Relaxing, auch nicht so Relaxing, ich brauch Relaxing Mario Musik, Relaxing Top Mario Musik,
Relaxing, Relaxing and Come, ja oh das ist gut, genau das muss, so muss das sein, ja
ich hab den großen Kolben auf den Tisch gehauen, so, also die Dinger müssen wir machen, dann
ich hab das größte Glück gehabt, ich hab, stellt es euch mal vor, oh was jetzt, warum
ruckelts, ach ne das ist die iPhone Kamera, die fokussiert, deswegen ruckelts, ich hab
zwei Raspberry Pi Zero 2 ergattert vor einer Weile, da brauch einer Pins für Luftfeuchtigkeit,
also der kommt als Ablösung in den Keller, schwachsinnig im Keller, Keller hab ich doch
schon anderen stehen, dann brauch ich den gar nicht, egal, wir machen trotzdem einen,
davon mit Pins, jetzt bin ich gerade aufgewacht, ich brauch den gar nicht im Keller, so, dann
muss ich noch zweimal Pins löten, zweimal Tiny Pico Pins, übrigens richtig nice, das
Board ist so ziemlich der kleinste ESP32, den man bekommen kann und das erste, wo ich
mal echt gespannt bin, ob ich das hinkriege, weil eigentlich, ich hab wechselbare Spitzen
dafür und ich hab zwei Spitzen, die werden jetzt äußerst praktisch, weil die relativ
klein sind, also man kann hier bei dem Lötkolben, Sekunde Leute, ich muss mal kurz hier das weg
machen, also man kann bei dem Lötkolben hier relativ easy, kann man hier abschrauben und
dann kann man hier auswechseln, man sollte das nicht unbedingt machen, wenn das Ding heiß
ist vorne, ne, ähm, die Sache ist nur die, ich hab dafür ziemlich praktische Spitzen
für was kleines heute, die Sache ist, ich find sie gerade nicht, ich dachte eigentlich,
ich hab alles in meiner Lötkiste drinne, da ist zumindest Lötzinn drinne, dieses Zeug
zum Lötzinn entfernen, das Multimeter ist alles drinne, aber irgendwie, ich hab keine
Ahnung warum die Spitzen für Lötkolben sind nicht da, keine Ahnung, so und dann als letztes,
das haben wir vor Jahren schon mal gemacht, auch im Stream, ich hab hier mir mal bei Aliexpress
was bestellt vor einer ganzen Weile und zwar ist das, ich machs mal kurz auf und zwar ist
das ein USB Schalter, da macht man da USB rein, hier USB rein und auf der anderen Seite
macht man ein Gerät dran und das Gerät kann man damit ein- und ausschalten, ist eigentlich
ziemlich cool, die Sache ist die, das braucht eine eigene Firmware, also muss man das Motor
draufflaschen, dass das ordentlich funktioniert und ich hab das, wir haben das vor Jahren
schon mal im Stream gemacht, da weiß ich noch, war das äußerst fummelig und heute probieren
wir das noch mal, also es hat geklappt, aber hier hab ich noch, hab ich auch einen, so
ein Flash Champ von Raspberry Pi, der Raspberry Pi steht da hinten, den seht ihr grad nicht,
ja und wenn wir grad beim Flaschen sind, einmal das Motor auf dieses Relay Teil hier, aber
vorher löten wir mal ein paar Headers an, ansonsten nix großartiges, ich löte, ihr
schreibt irgendwas in Chat und wir schwätzen ein bisschen, das ist der Plan heute, warum
haben Hubs so ein Feature nicht, was für Hubs, das ist wahr, so hab ich das noch gar nicht
gesehen, so hab ich das noch gar nicht gesehen, also das heißt, weil Modern Warfare 2022
mehr Zweien hat, gewinnts, ja ist eigentlich klar oder, Leute ich muss euch was anderes
erzählen bevor wir anfangen, ich hab mich heute wahnsinnig aufgeregt, über Bürokratie
kam wieder, tja wahrscheinlich, weil sie nicht wollte, dass du in die Nähe gehst, ach USB
Hubs, ja das frage ich mich auch, USB Hubs wo du Remote Sachen ein und ausschalten kannst
werden äußerst praktisch, also Leute ich hab mich heute wahnsinnig über Bürokratie
aufgeregt und zwar, ja also ich hab ja heute Morgen auf Twitter gefragt, ob irgendjemand
von euch weiß, guckt zu euch an, ob man für einen, wenn man einen Personalausweis beantragen
muss, ob man das dann schon modern mit digitalem Bild machen kann oder ob man noch ausdrucken
muss oder ob man sich echte Passbilder besorgen muss und die einstimmige Meinung, das Chat,
in dem Fall auf Twitter, der Twitter Chat, war, man braucht Passbilder beziehungsweise
es gehen auch selbstgemachte, aber man muss sie dann wohl ausdrucken, krankschreibung
betrendet, ok Sekunde, das muss ich mir mal kurz angucken, was, Isolation bei Corona Infektion
ab 1. Mai nur noch freiwillig, ja die Logik kann mir auch keiner erklären, was da abgeht,
jetzt machen wir 2 Jahre den Aufwand des Todes und jetzt ist es auf einmal trotz so hohen
Infektionszahlen wie noch nie alles kein Problem mehr, das muss ich alles nicht verstehen.
Oh und Hyperinflation trendet auch, nein ich darf mir keine Trends angucken, ich darf
mir keine deutschen Trends angucken, das ist immer gefährlich, so zumindest ich wollte
einen neuen Ausweis haben, übrigens jetzt wo wir ja auch gerade die Hyperinflation gesehen
haben, wisst ihr warum ich einen neuen Ausweis brauche, gut jetzt werdet ihr wahrscheinlich
sagen, ja weil mein Alter abgelaufen ist, ja darauf will ich nicht raus, ja mein Alter
ist abgelaufen, aber ich möchte endlich mal meine Kohle halbwegs sinnig anlegen und
dann natürlich nach Madeira ziehen, wie man das so macht, ja logisch, natürlich, und ich
werde einen großen Teil wahrscheinlich in ETFs stecken, so dass ich, ich bin kein großartiger
Stonks Zocker, das wisst ihr, ich will nur irgendwas, wo die Chance zumindest da ist,
dass es nicht extrem viel weniger wird, was dir sonst die nächsten paar Jahre passieren
wird.
Also ich werde garantiert nicht All in Gamestops machen, ich werde irgendeinen ETF World, fragt
mich nicht, nehmen, so und dann wollte ich mir zumindest eine Broker App installieren,
beziehungsweise ich wollte mir einen Account machen bei Scalable heißen die glaube ich,
da muss man Postident machen, der Gamer Alex, ja genau, glaube ich zumindest oder was ähnliches,
ich bin da gerade am Lesen aber ich will auf jeden Fall nicht mein Geld mehr sinnlos rumliegen
lassen, aber ich werde das auch nicht alles auf einmal machen oder sowas, also zumindest
habe ich mir eine Broker App installiert, Account gemacht und da muss man Postident machen und
damit Postident funktioniert, braucht man einen gültigen Ausweis, theoretisch, theoretisch
geht auch Reisepass oder Führerschein vielleicht auch, aber ich brauche auf jeden Fall einen
Ausweis, muss eh mal, muss eh mal wieder machen, so und jetzt, und jetzt kommt's, dachte mir
so nichts Schlimmes, Passfotos habe ich mittlerweile, kein Problem, guckst du mal bei der Stadt
Hanau, die hat nämlich eine Seite, die nennt sich Hanau Digital, der Hanauer Bürgerservice,
genau der, die Seite die aussieht wie von 1995, oh Flashbang, Führerschein geht leider
nicht, na Reisepass habe ich gar keinen, Online-Ident, ja ja ja ja, Online-Ident ist das gleiche,
wenn du Online-Ident machst, wenn du Online-Ident machst, dann musst du halt in die Kamera
halten dein, dein Ausweis, ist doch egal, also ich habe die Post heute gefragt auf Twitter,
das geht nicht mit einem abgelaufenen Ausweis, zumindest dachte ich mir kein Problem, Stadt
Hanau, Passbilder habe ich mir besorgt mittlerweile, Stadt Hanau, buchst du dir einen Termin online,
jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's, pass mal auf, wichtig ist natürlich, dass meine Sitzung
in 24 Minuten abläuft, bei so einer Seite, ganz ganz wichtig, ja, so Bürgerservice, du
hast eine Passangelegenheit, ich will einen Personalausweis beantragen, allein schon diese
komische Warenkorbzeug hier, und jetzt kommt's, pass mal auf weiter, ok, und jetzt kriegst
du Vorschläge, Blog, jetzt kriegst du Vorschläge, die Url, Alter, anguckt euch die Url an, ey,
können wir das faken, kann man damit vielleicht das, oh wir gucken gleich, ob man das Datum
faken kann, dass ich einen Termin kriege, obwohl man eigentlich gar keinen kriegen soll, so,
zumindest guckt mal, nächster Termin, am 5.5., das in einem Monat, ernsthaft, in einem Monat,
ich brauch jetzt, und sei es nur, sei es nur einen vorläufigen Personalausweis, ich brauch
einen Ausweis, Alter, wollen die mich verarschen, in einem Monat, so, da hab ich heute angerufen
bei denen, und ich hab nen Screenshot, den kann ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich
mein Handy hier, mein Handy als Kamera verwende, ähm, dann hab ich dort versucht anzurufen,
und ich war mehrfach 30 Minuten in der Warteschleife, und es ist keiner drangegangen, ja, was ist
das denn, das, also das ist doch blanker Hohen, das überhaupt Bürgerservice zu nehmen, doch
die bieten Video-Ident an, aber du brauchst trotzdem einen gültigen Ausweis, außer, geht
die Krankenkasse-Karte vielleicht, geht die Krankenkasse vielleicht, ne, ne, ja, ich komm
wohl, ich komm wohl an einem Ausweis nicht vorbei, aber ich mein, in einem Monat sind
die denn noch bei, sind die denn noch ganz dicht, und anrufen dann auch nicht funktioniert,
wisst ihr was, jetzt probieren wir mal was, jetzt, wir probieren jetzt mal was aus, select,
wir gucken jetzt mal was die Seite macht, Achtung, Hacker-Content hier, ähm, nix, okay, weiter,
das macht auch keine Requests, okay, okay, also das hier ist wohl der, das hier ist dann
wohl die Uhr, die aufgerufen wird, ah, hier sind Terminvorschläge drin, okay, dann wählen
wir einfach mal einen Termin aus, hat das jetzt noch einen Request geschickt, wenn ich
einen Termin auswähle, ja, hat einen Request geschickt, hier, so, und steckt, lasst uns
das mal angucken, steckt in diesem Request, ne, in Cookies wird das gespeichert, oder,
also in der Uhr steht der Termin nicht drin, sonst wäre er jetzt hier gesetzt, das steht
in irgendwelchen Cookies drin, schau doch, ob es bei einer anderen Stadt in der Nähe
schneller geht, das ist eine gute Idee, weil letztendlich für den Personalausweisbeantrag
ist doch eigentlich egal, wo ich da hingehe, oder, so, Cookies, wo setzen die das denn,
Cookies, wie, die haben das encrypted, die wollen mir noch nicht ernsthaft erzählen,
dass die das secure gemacht haben, hättet ihr das vermutet, Cookies sind encrypted,
ne, warte mal, show all decoded, ne, warum ist das, warum ist das secure, das, ist das
vielleicht, ist das vielleicht base64, decode, ne, das ist irgendein token, also hier drinne
müssten jetzt eigentlich meine Sachen gespeichert sein, wir können auch local storage gucken,
gibt's nix, session storage, gibt's nix, ne, die haben das tatsächlich so gemacht,
dass man den Termin nicht faken kann, das finde ich aber nicht nett von denen jetzt,
Cyberchef, stimmt das recht, das ist ja blöd, al-session, also in der url steckt's auf
jeden fall schon mal nicht drinne, guck mal, wenn ich hier klicke, guck mal mal, was der
genau macht, wenn ich hier klicke, ne, dann lädt er noch, hier personal data, was haben
wir denn da, personal data, ach ne, das ist die seite, gucken wir mal, was im request
drinne steht, header, das cookie, ne, also da Termin ist wahrscheinlich wirklich im cookie
drinne, ich mein man könnte das jetzt absenden und gucken was er dann macht, aber das will
ich nicht, da reservierst du dir ja einen Termin, also irgendwie muss da sich den Termin
hier gemerkt haben, wobei guck mal, ich mein der Termin steht auf der Seite, aber das ist
bestimmt serverseitig gerendert oder, das ist doch bestimmt serverseitig gerendert,
du kannst das Datum ändern, echt, wo, ja, ne, das ist nicht serverseitig gerendert,
doch, das ist serverseitig gerendert, ach kacke, ich glaube ich kann kein Termin faken
gescheit, beim Bürgerservice Hanau, inspekt vom button, excellent, du meinst hier, submit,
choose Termin, du meinst dem da vorne, ach hier, check mal, ja, sehr gute Idee, submit
button, suggest, Moment, kann man das, wartet mal, nehmen die den Inhalt von hier, ne, die
nehme ich den Inhalt von hier, oder, ne, ne, ne, das wärs jetzt auch, die zwei Zeilen
da drüber, ach hier, guck mal, input hidden value weak, da kann man was ändern, tatsächlich,
ne, Moment, das ist der Filter, oder, ne, das ist nicht der Filter, das ist tatsächlich
das Ding hier, also kann ich, kann ich quasi sagen, day, warum ist day 4, was ist wenn
ich sage, day 3, und dann drauf klicke, hä, ok, ne, keine Ahnung, ach, das ist day Mittwoch,
ah Moment, da muss man, wahrscheinlich, hier, date, hier kann ich wahrscheinlich einfach
eintragen, also vierter, fünfter, vierter, mal gucken, ob das Ami Datum ist, oder was,
na gut, keine Chance, sich hier irgendwelche Termine zu, funktioniert nicht, na gut, na
gut, zumindest hab ich keine Chance gehabt, mir einen neuen Ausweis zu beantragen, und
ich brauch das für die Broker App als Postident, damit mein Geld nicht bald nur noch die Hälfte
wert ist, das ist ja doof, dass es nicht geht, das bestimmt, ich versuch morgen noch mal
anzurufen, wenn nicht, wenn nicht, ruf ich mal 115 an, 115 ist ja diese Behörden-Hotline,
ja, weil das umsonst ist, also weil du mit dem Free Broker bei Scalable bloß irgendwie
9,90 Cent pro Transaktion oder so bezahlst und irgendwie sonst nix, und weil das überall
empfohlen wird, hätte wahrscheinlich genauso gut funktioniert, ja, von dem hab ich ein
paar Videos geguckt, nein, man kann nicht hingehen und eine Nummer ziehen, das geht
nur für manche Sachen, nicht für den Personalausweis, tja, keine Ahnung, es ist zumindest blöd,
dass das nicht funktioniert.
Es ist im Prinzip egal, die brauchen auch Postident, die brauchen alle, du brauchst
überall einen gültigen Ausweis, wenn du Postident machen willst, was ziemlich hängen geblieben
ist, na gut, wobei, ich kann's ja verstehen, die müssen sich ja auch absichern, es ist
eher hängen geblieben, dass die Stadt Hanau 6 Wochen braucht, bis sie mir einen Ausweis,
nein, stimmt ja nicht, 6 Wochen bis ich einen Termin bekomme, um einen neuen Ausweis zu
beantragen, der braucht ja auch noch mal 2-3 Wochen, sind ETF safe oder kann es immer
was crashen, sobald du Aktien kaufst, die Sache ist halt nie, wenn du irgendwie möglichst
breit, also ich bin wirklich nicht der große Finanzbrain, ja, aber wenn du irgendeinen
World ETF nimmst, der quasi mehr oder weniger den Markt der ganzen Welt abbildet, der wird
heute nicht um 15% steigen, der wird aber morgen wahrscheinlich auch nicht instant um 15% fallen
und auf lange Sicht sind wohl die Chancen ganz gut, dass er hochgeht, sofern die Weltwirtschaft
ganz gut flutscht, nein, haben sie nicht, haben sie nicht, haben sie nicht, nein, ich lass
mich bei mir nicht beraten, das letzte was ich mache, lass ich mich von unseren Beratern
beraten lassen, das glaubst du aber, im Leben nicht, die verkaufen ja erstmal eine Lebensversicherung
oder sowas, das kannst du vergessen, sie bated, guck mal Nightbot hat ein Alien, ne, das ist
ein Roboter, also nicht Area 51, ganz ehrlich, scheiß drauf, ich brauch ihn jetzt halt,
wisst ihr auch wo ich überhaupt keinen Bock habe, Fingerabdrücke abzugeben für meinen
neuen Ausweis, hab ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, man ist jetzt ja quasi schon halb
kriminell, weil man den Personalausweis beantragen will, klar, da brauchen wir natürlich Fingerabdrücke
für, das mit dem Goldfisch haben wir auch schon gesehen, ja, das ist jetzt Pflicht mit
Fingerabdrücken, seit einem halben Jahr oder so, nein, nein, das ist mittlerweile Pflicht,
kannst du den Ausweis nicht in einer anderen Stadt machen, doch, das ist eine gute Idee,
kann man das, Personalausweis, andere Stadt beantragen, auch in jedem anderen Bürgeramt
beantragen, hey, das ist eine gute Idee, was gibt's denn, da muss ich mal kurz gucken,
wie sieht's denn in Frankfurt, ich geh einfach nach Frankfurt, ich geh einfach nach Frankfurt,
wo ist sie, Bürger, Bürgerservice, Terminservice, was, ich kann kein Kyrillisch, online Terminvereinbarung,
mal gucken, wann man da was bekommt, bequem von zu Hause, Online-Dienst, Anmeldung einer
Wohnung, Ausweis, Personalausweis, sag mal, das ist doch die gleiche Kacksoftware, oder,
vorläufiger Personalausweis beantragen, Terminvereinbaren, jaja, was du im Essen bestellst, also wo ich
mega Bock drauf hätte, jetzt wäre Köfteteller, Sachsenhausen, in Frankfurt, was ist das da
ohne für'n Knopf, ist das, ist die Seite, ist die Seite broken von denen, die Seite,
wir gucken mal was anderes, Offenbach, Leute, Haftbefehl, Bürgerservice, nicht Offenbeck,
Bürgerbüro, Offenbach, meint ihr, das ist der Dark-Reader, der da Probleme macht, Sekunde,
was ist das, meint ihr, dass der Dark-Reader da Probleme macht, nee, das sind einfach noch
keine, Offenbach, wir gucken jetzt Offenbach, Hafti-Abi, Offenbach, Terminplaner, die haben
auch diesen Kack, Bürgerbüro, Melde, Pässe, nein, Pässe und Ausweise, okay, weiter, okay,
ich geh' nach Offenbach, Leute, auf geht's nach Offenbach, ich geh' einfach nach Offenbach,
easy, dazu kann ich nur sagen, da will wahrscheinlich keiner hin sonst, nee, da fahr' ich nicht
mal, wo ist denn das, Kaiserstraße 39, ich wusste gar nicht, dass die in Offenbach auch
eine Kaiserstraße haben, Offenbach, wo ist denn das, Map, beim Leder-Museum, das ist
gut, da ist eine S-Bahn-Haltestelle, Kaiserstraße 39, Offenbach, da fahr' ich mit der S-Bahn
von Hanau aus, easy, Kaiserstraße 39, Chat, ihr seid richtig Pfeifett, auf die Idee, dass
ich, dass ich einfach in eine andere Stadt gehe, bin ich gar nicht gekommen, hast du
keine Bedenken, meine Adresse zu leaken, das ist nicht meine Adresse, das ist die Adresse
in Offenbach vom Bürgerservice, so, was haben wir, wie kommt man da am besten hin, jetzt
holen wir mal Bahn, holen wir mal Bahn, gucken wir mal, ob die da was Gescheites haben, Hanau,
Kaiserstraße 39, Offenbach, keine Ahnung, morgen, Mittag, irgendwann, suchen, 7 Minuten
Fußweg, easy Leute, guckt euch das mal an, 8 Minuten Zugfahrt, warum bin ich, warum gehe
ich überhaupt noch nach Hanau, Offenbach, Habt ihr, Habt ihr, Habt ihr Abi regelt,
da geh ich hin, ich mach mal Termin in Offenbach, geh von Offenbach, fertig, Habt ihr Abi regelt,
was haben die für, was haben die für, für Bewertungen Offenbach, Bürgerbüro, was haben
die für Bewertungen, Bürgerbüro, wo ist das hier, hä, sag mal bin ich blöd, das ist
doch eben hier einfach verschwunden, da stand doch eben noch Bürgerbüro, jetzt ist es
einfach weg, Bürgerbüro, guckt, ist einfach weg, Bürgerbüro, Offenbach, ja, da, genau,
Stadtverwaltung, die hat das, sehr gute, wann machen die auf, Dienstag, 8 bis 13 Uhr,
Sortieren, neueste, guck mal, der ist richtig begeistert, die sind richtig begeistert hier,
die Leute, vom Offenbacher, Stelz, Gürtelstraße, Louis Vitor Store, zahlen die Kollektion
Bar, Fick auf Sponsor, Haftbefehl weiß bescheiden, Offenbach kann es anscheinend auch, nice,
ok Leute, ihr habt mir schon wieder sehr geholfen, Chet, absolut Fivehead, high IQ, ich gehe
nach Offenbach und betran trage meinen, meinen Ausweis, ganz einfach, Kugelsichere Weste,
Kugelsichere Weste ist auch schon eingepackt, wozu ich den brauche, Postident, Postident
für eine Broker App, alternativ könnte ich auch alles in Schweizer Franken stecken, das
wird wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren, das gibt es heute zu lösen, bald Euro weniger
wert als Schweizer Franken, ist es nicht jetzt schon so, ist es nicht jetzt schon so, dass
du irgendwie für einen Schweizer Franken, keine Ahnung, nur 0,92 Euro kriegst oder
so, oder ist umgedreht, ach nee 1,01, ach so, wie, Moment, das geht runter, wait a minute,
ich dachte es geht hoch, nein, ich kaufe keine Schweizer Franken, so, gut, jetzt hätten
wir das geklärt, Chet, Chet hat mir sehr geholfen, also nur für die Frage, was wir heute zu lösen
haben, nichts großartig spektakuläres, ein paar Hedder Pins an Raspberry Pis, ein paar
Hedder Pins an Tiny Pico ESP32 und ein paar D1 Minis und dieses Ding hier, das gucken
wir uns jetzt an, wo wir gerade schon dabei sind, und zwar, habe ich ja gerade schon gezeigt,
das ist ein Schalter, da machst du USB-Geräte rein und kannst die USB-Geräte, also mit
dem Knopfdruck kannst du die hier schalten oder aber Remote, wenn du das Motor drauf
flashst, die Sache ist, um flashen zu können, muss man das aufmachen und irgendwo hier innen
drinnen an die Pins löten, das haben wir auch schon mal in einem Stream gemacht vor
zwei Jahren, das heißt, im Zweifelsfall kann ich einfach in mein Archiv gucken, wie ich
das damals gemacht habe, ich mach das Ding mal kurz auf, wir gucken uns mal kurz die
Pins da drinnen an, ich muss übrigens irgendwie mein Setup hier ein bisschen ändern, weil
ich, ich, ich kann das euch, also da, da, so in die Richtung, wo mein Daumen jetzt, da,
hier, so da, da, in die Richtung, da ist mein Kopf und genau da oben drüber ist das
Elgato Ringlight, das Problem ist, genau da, wo ich meinen Kopf hin machen will, ist das
Ringlight, das ist ziemlich pepeger, das heißt, wenn ich hier, das heißt, ich muss jetzt
einen Schritt zurück gehen, wenn ich überhaupt was sehen will hier, also ich, mal gucken,
wie man das aufmacht, am besten, so schon mal nicht, aha, ich hab's, easy, schon ist
auf, noch ein bisschen, es will nicht so ganz, guck mal hier, ah, jetzt, gut, jetzt haben
wir dieses Ding, wo hat es denn hier, lass mich mal kurz gucken, chat, ich guck jetzt
selbst auf mein Monitor, weil die Kamera bessere Auflösung als meine Boomer Augen hat, wo
sind hier die, auf, Mensch, Kamera, wo sind die Pins zum Tranlöten, hier, oh fuck, oh,
das wird eklig, guckt euch das mal an, Sekunde, ich zeig euch das, ich brauch mal ein Stückchen,
ich brauch ein Papier, dass ihr es besser seht, oh Mensch, ich brauch ein Papier, wo
nix drauf ist, oder ich machs euch auf den Schwamm, guckt mal hier oben, seht ihr das,
das sind die Pins, da muss ich dran, oben in der Mitte, seht ihr das, das da, das da,
das ist natürlich ganz besonders praktisch, dass ich grad meine kleinere Lötspitze nicht
finde, das ist sehr unvorteilhaft jetzt, GG, wartet mal kurz, ich brauch mal ein paar
Pins, kriegt man da überhaupt gescheit Kabel dran, kriegt man da überhaupt gescheit, ne,
das Mann, das funktioniert im Leben nicht, mein Gott, ey Kamera, iPhone, Stells, das Ding
ist, der Pin ist doppelt so groß wie das Loch, aber wenn ich das schräg mache, geht das
wahrscheinlich, jetzt ist nur die große Preisfrage, was davon ist Ground, was davon, ich hol mal
kurz, ich hol mal kurz, was für einfacheren Lötstels, ich hab mir vor ner Weile hier
sowas gekauft, das ist, bisschen staubig gerade, das ist relativ praktisch das Teil, da kann
man, guck mal, ich brauch da nur einen, ich brauch nur einen Arm, die anderen, äh mal
weg, da kann man das einklemmen und sich dann so hin, hindingsen wie man das braucht, das
ist äußerst praktisch, aber das Problem ist viel eher, was ich hier sehe ist, ich meine
ernsthaft, guckt euch mal an, wie klein das ist, oben links, da komm ich nicht gescheit
dran und die nächste Sache ist, woher weiß ich, ja gut, da kann ich in meinem Archivstream
gucken, XY, guck mal, da steht was drauf, XY, XYWF USB, da gucken wir mal im Internet,
XYWF USB, aha, ja da kommen wir der Sache doch schon näher, aha, guck mal da und schon
haben wir ne Beschriftung, was was ist, drei, also, ok, ok, also wenn ich das richtig sehe,
GG Eats, also wenn ich das richtig sehe, ganz links der ist 3,3 Volt, Reset, Reset brauche
ich nicht, GPIO 0, RX TX Ground, ja, dann probieren wir das doch mal, das, oh das wird
abfuck Leute, ich sag es euch, das da dran zu bekommen, RX TX, also was brauchen wir
denn, also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall 3,3 Volt, Reset brauchen wir nicht, GPIO 0 braucht
man glaube ich, wie war das zum Flashen, wie war das zum Flashen, GPIO 0 muss auf Ground,
was der in Flash Modus geht, weiß es gar nicht mehr, bei einem ESP866, was das ist,
das ist ein USB Schalter, da kannst du USB Geräte mit ein und ausschalten, stell dir
vor du hast eine USB Kamera oder irgendwas, oder eine USB Kaffeemaschine, ne, keine Ahnung,
irgendwelche USB Geräte, die kannst du Remote da mit ein und ausschalten, eigentlich ziemlich
coole Geschichte, wenn man es geflasht hat, das funktioniert nur wenn man es gescheit
geflasht hat, ok, das wird jetzt spannend das da dran zu bekommen, das wird was, also
3,3 Volt, Flashing, FTDI Adapter, den habe ich da liegen, I did it with some, was sind
denn sie, ey das ist eine Idee, das ist eine gute Idee Leute, was der Typ da hatte, guck
mal wir könnten, anstatt, anstatt dass wir da so komische Jumperkabel dran machen, anstatt
dass wir so Jumperkabel dran machen, könnte ich ganz dünne, könnte ich sowas hier nehmen,
guck mal, hier, könnte ich sowas hier nehmen, wie geht denn das los, da, guck mal das sind
ganz dünne Kabel, die kriege ich da viel besser dran, da müssen wir mal einen Abisoliertchamp
holen kurz, guck mal der Abisoliertchamp kriegt das kleine Kabel doch nicht mal abisoliert,
so klein ist das, das ist dumm, ich hab grad nichts anderes da zum Abisolieren, egal ich
hab's, guck mal wir könnten das direkt dran löten, das ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser,
das machen wir, das ist eine gute Idee, ESP 2866 Flash GPIO 0, Muster GPIO 0 auf Ground,
die Resetleitung und GPIO 0, GPIO, Low beim Booten aktiviert, Firmware Upload, ok, also,
ok Reset brauche ich nicht, ich brauche GPIO 0, RX TX, Ground und 3,3 Volt, also im Prinzip
brauche ich alles außer den zweiten Pin, das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut, ob ich das
auf die Reihe kriege, ne da passt keine Leiste dran, das ist, guck mal, das ist ultra klein,
ich zeige es dir nochmal, das ist, du siehst meinen Daumen daneben, ja, das ist ultra klein,
ja probieren wir mal, da bin ich mal gespannt ob du das findest, testen wir mal, ich teste
es mal mit dem 3,3 Volt Kabel, ja und zum Flashen, zum Flashen brauchen wir dann den
Kulesh hier, das ist ein ganz normaler FTDI Adapter, also quasi ein, im Prinzip ist es
nichts anderes als ein USB, USB auf Serial Adapter und wichtig, guck mal, weil ich es
hier gerade sehe, man kann das einstellen auf 5 Volt oder 3,3 Volt und es steht standardmäßig
auf 5 Volt, das ist schlecht, weil 5 Volt wird das Ding hier wahrscheinlich kaputt machen,
deswegen jumperen wir das gleich mal um auf Jumper auf 3,3 Volt, ok, ja, dann, Aua, Leute,
das ist wirklich störend hier wo mich die Katze gekratzt hat, guckt euch das mal an,
das ist genau vorne, alter Kamera scharf stellen please, das ist genau hier vorne am Finger,
den ich jetzt brauche, Kamera stell dich mal scharf, kein Bock, will nicht, vielleicht
auch Twitch Schutz gegen Selbstverletzungen oder so, so wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit,
lohnt sich das überhaupt oder ist besser ich leg das hin, hol mal das Ding was bitte
kleiner ist, kleineres Tentakel, aja ja, ok, ja so müsste es eigentlich ganz gut passen,
ok, schauen wir mal, mal gucken ob ich das dran kriege, da, da muss ich hin, ganz links,
also hier der da, der da müsste 3,3 Volt sein, guckt 3,3 Volt ist der am USB Anschluss, also
der da ist, man kann das gar nicht richtig erkennen, der da ist 3,3 Volt, da muss jetzt
das Kabel dran, ESD, ach Quatsch, als nächstes ziehe ich mir noch so ein Armband an oder
so, wobei, ganz ehrlich ich habe so ein Armband, aber selbst wenn es kaputt geht, so probieren
wir das mal aus, mal einschalten, Lötge, ach so weil die Fragen öfters kommen, ich
kann es euch an der Stelle auch noch mal zeigen, ich habe mir vor ein paar Jahren, das war eine
wirklich gute Investition, ich habe mir vor ein paar Jahren so eine Ersa, so eine Ersa
Lötstation gekauft und das coole an dem Ding ist, dass der, dadurch dass du hier die Station
hast, ich schalte mal an, dadurch dass du hier die Station hast und nicht alles im Lötkolben
selbst drinne hast, du hast den Lötkolben an sich, der ist halt sehr klein und handlich
und hat austauschbaren Kopf und sowas, Spitze, also das Ding ist an Geld wert finde ich,
aber wenn man nur ab und zu mal ein bisschen was löst, ist natürlich nicht erforderlich
oder so, geht bloß darum, wenn man öfters mal was macht bzw. wenn man die Kohle übrig
hat, ist das was, was ich echt empfehlen kann, so ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen Platz machen,
so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich das dran kriege, ach du Scheiße, ok erst mal,
erst mal das, zack, erst mal mal meine Lötspitze mal ein bisschen, so, also wie kriegen wir
das denn jetzt am besten dran, wir kürzen das Kabel nochmal ne Runde, so, kriegt man
das da dran, wir können, wir könnten das Kabel vorher mal, ein bisschen Zinn ans Kabel, vielleicht
geht das jetzt ja direkt, hast du auch eine Heißluftstation, ja, ich hab halt keine Heißluftstation,
ich hab von Steinen so ein Heißluftgebläse mit einem Aufsatz, um das kleiner zu machen,
das reicht mir, also da ist kein, also hier ist keine Heißluftsachen direkt dabei, so,
sieht man was, ich muss mal so machen, dass ihr das seht und ich auch, fuck alter, boah
ist das klein man, vielleicht soll ich das so machen, alter das ist mega, mega klein,
da kommst du, also ich bräuchte auf jeden Fall erst mal die andere Spitze, die ich grad
nicht finde, hast du schon mal überlegt Videos auf Englisch zu machen, ich hab ja mal Just
for Fun ein paar Videos auf Englisch gemacht, aber das war ja nur, wie gesagt, nicht weil
ich da groß etwas mit machen wollte, glaub ich muss das doch hinlegen, sonst wackele
ich zu sehr rum, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen Lötzinn drauf und jetzt mal gucken, mal gucken
ob ich jetzt das Kabel irgendwie dran krieg, ey, ok, hm, das ist eigentlich sogar ganz
ok, hätt ich nicht gedacht, aber passt, gut, ist sogar, wie ihr seht, also es hält, ok,
also unser 3,3 Volt haben wir schon mal dran und vielleicht, vielleicht hab ich Glück,
weil das 3,3 Volt, das kann ich auf der anderen Seite hier direkt ranlöten, aber RxTx, das
muss ich stecken, glaub ich, wobei ich kann RxTx auch dranlöten hier, warum nicht, hm,
was jetzt noch ganz praktisch wäre, noch mal zumindest eine andere Farbe, dass ich nachher
erkenne, was was ist, ich hab von diesen Rollen noch mehr irgendwo, wartet mal, mal kurz gucken,
gibt es keine passende Buchsenleiste, möglich, aber du siehst, wie gesagt, das hier neben
ist mein Daumen, das ist verdammt klein und selbst wenn, danach muss das ja wieder in das
Gehäuse rein, dann müsste ich die Leiste wieder auslöten, so guck mal Leute, was ich
gefunden hab, ich hab den Kram noch in Dutzend billiger, also komm, was brauchen wir noch,
wir nehmen noch blau und schwarz für ground, komm, wir sind mal ganz, ganz, super, ordentlich,
was wird das, ich versuche hier dran, da ist ein ESP866 drauf und ich versuche hier oben
dran, was, dran zu löten, dass ich custom firmware flaschen kann, du siehst, wie klein
das ist, ich mein, du erkennst so quasi fast schon die Poren auf der Haut und du siehst
die Löcher kaum, ok, das nächste hab ich nicht gebraucht, oder, reset, reset brauch
ich nicht, GPIO 0 brauch ich, GPIO 0, GPIO 0 kriegt schwarz, das ist ok, GPIO 0 kriegt
ein schwarzes Kabel und ground kriegt auch ein schwarzes Kabel, aber das werde ich, das
werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht verwechseln, ok, so, noch ein bisschen Lötzinn da vorne
dran wieder, weil eigentlich, der ist wahrscheinlich besser, mach da frisches Lötzinn dran, jetzt
bräuchte ich mein Fluxpen, Leute, jetzt bräuchte ich mein Fluxpen, aber mein Fluxpen liegt
noch bei DHL rum, dann hätt ich ordentliches Flussmittel, da würde das auch besser flutschen
alles mit, so und was wir jetzt machen, bevor wir das Kabel da dran löten ist, ich mach
erstmal, ich mach erstmal auf jeden dieser, ich mein ich hätte auch hier ne Lupe, aber
wir machen erstmal ein bisschen Lötzinn auf jeden dieser Kontakte hier drauf, ich bräuchte
echt mein Lötzinn mit der kleineren Spitze, bzw. ich bräuchte die Spitze, ok, jetzt haben
wir da ein bisschen Lötzinn dran, so was brauchen wir jetzt überhaupt, das hab ich
nicht aufgepasst, die hinteren zwei, der hintere war Ground ne, Ground TXRX, so jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt, ob das funst, also Lötzinn haben wir drauf hinten, bräuchten wir hier
fort, oh das, ey, wisst ihr was die Scheiße ist, ich löte das wahrscheinlich wieder ab,
ich hab ne Idee, kriegt man das hier durch, kriegt man das hier durch, guckt mal, kriegt
man das vielleicht, da durch, ne, shit, kriegt man nicht, liegt an der Technik, ja das kann
auch sein, boah das ist ja abfuck, ah ich hab ne Idee, ne hab ich nicht, ich hab ne Idee,
wir machen das einfach abwechselnd, guck mal, das ist, das ist, wir machen das abwechselnd,
ich mach oben, ich mach oben einen dran und den nächsten mach ich unten dran, dass ich
das nicht Gefahr laufe den Kram abzulöten, das ist das ne gute Idee, so der nächste Pin
ist Reset, den lassen wir frei, also den übernächsten Pin, also den übernächsten Pin, muss ich
schon mal kurz hinsetzen, dass ich da was sehe, den übernächsten Pin, hm, der hat noch
kein Lötzchen drauf, jetzt hat er Lötzchen drauf, das ist wirklich abverklein alter, ok
ich glaube das hält, aha, so, haben wir, sogar relativ stabil, heute ist nicht aktuell,
ne, was wird gerade gemacht, wie gesagt, das hier ist ein Schalter für USB Geräte mit
dem ESP286 drauf und ich möchte Custom Firmware drauf machen, damit ich das Ding überhaupt
gescheit verwenden kann, das ist Mario Galaxy Musik, das ist die Musik, die kenn ich noch,
das ist, wenn Rosalina den Lumas aus dem Bilderbuch vorliest, das ist wirklich Pepo Z, das ist
übrigens auch der Grund warum ich immer noch finde Mario Galaxy ist das beste Mario Game,
das ist das einzige Mario Game mit einer Geschichte, die irgendwie nennenswert ist, andere Mario
Games haben keine Story, die haben, oh nein, die Prinzessin ist weg, du musst die Welt
retten, so, deswegen ist, finde ich, Mario Galaxy Pock, gut, also das haben wir, jetzt
fehlen uns RX-TX, wie kriege ich da RX-TX dran, das ist so klein und nebeneinander, also ich
habe 3,3 Volt dran und GPIO 0 RX-TX Crown, Crown machen wir zum Schluss, übrigens, ich
muss mal Chat gucken, also wenn ich die Hälfte übersehen habe, weil wir können Chat doch
eigentlich direkt hier gucken, brauch ich doch eigentlich gar nichts, Chat können wir hier
gucken, ne, habe ich nicht, ja, ich habe auch schon ein paar Sachen im Stream abgefackelt
aus Versehen, ja, das stimmt schon, okay, die Musik ist aus, nochmal, solltest du basteln,
wie gesagt, ich versuche gerade hier dran, an die Pins dran zu kommen, dass ich den Kram
flaschen kann gleich, okay, eigentlich brauche ich doch jetzt nur die nächsten zwei, RX-TX
irgendwie, nehmen wir mal das Blaue und ich habe eine Idee, wisst ihr was wir machen können,
5-Hat-Time, Leute, 5-Hat-Time, also ich abisoliere das mal schnell, so, wisst ihr was wir machen
können, guck mal, das ist doch das Kabel vorne, das ist ja nicht durchgängig, wir können
jetzt einfach die Hälfte, guck mal, die Hälfte nehmen von dem Kabel und gucken, es ist halt
so furzig klein, man sieht nichts, die Hälfte von dem Kabel nehmen und gucken, ob man die
in die Löcher gesteckt bekommt, so quasi, das dürfte das ganze nämlich deutlich einfacher
machen, schaut mal, wie ich mir das denke, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, man könnte
das hier einfach reinstöpseln, boah, ich sehe nichts, Boomer Augen, Alter, das müsste
funktionieren, das ist so eine schlechte Idee, dass die funktioniert, ja, die wird funktionieren,
ich mach mal ein bisschen Lötschen vorne dran an das Kabel, einfach, dass es ordentlich
zusammen bleibt, so, und jetzt, und jetzt, ich zeige es euch gleich, sollte es funktionieren,
hey, schaut mal her, es funzt, fuck, und ich habe das andere Kabel abgemacht, scheiße,
aber guckt mal, hier, es funzt, das machen wir so, guckt hier, seht ihr das, man kann
das da durchstecken, das ist gut, Pogchamp, so machen wir das, so machen wir das bei dem
anderen auch, easy, easy, ich sollte mal einen ordentlichen Seitenschneider holen, ich muss
mal kurz Seiten schneider holen, warte mal, Max115, rate mal, wie alt ich bin, weil nur
weil ich auf Twitch streame und in Twitch Emotes rede, heißt es ja nicht zwangsläufig,
weil ich wahnsinnig jung bin, 48, 6, 69, 19, ich wäre gerne 19 Leute, 19 sein, war Pogchamp,
19 sein war richtig Pogchamp, ok Leute, der Plan geht auf, der Plan funktioniert, mit
dem durchziehen, der Plan wirkt sozusagen, oh jetzt muss ich das noch festlöten, 27
bis 29, ne ich bin 37, ich sehe nichts, das ist so klein, hey ich hab's, was, übrigens
habt ihr schon meinen selbst gebastelten Pop-Schutz gesehen für das Headset, schaut mal her, der
Pop-Schutz ist 1000 mal besser als der offizielle Pop-Schutz, weil guckt mal, ihr merkt kaum
was davon, weil der ist richtig guter Pop-Schutz, und jetzt wisst ihr auch, warum ich hier random
so einen Autoschwamm rumliegen habe, den habe ich für den Pop-Schutz, das aus dem Teil
des Schwammes ist der Pop-Schutz geworden, das ist richtig huge, ok, so jetzt haben wir
das dran, ähm nächstes, also, dann nehmen wir, dann nehmen wir noch einfach das schwarze
Kabel, was wir haben, alles vorne ab, ich glaube so reicht, ich glaube vielmehr müssen
wir da gar nicht abmachen, einfach wirklich so ein ganz kleines, kleines Stückchen, so
und jetzt machen wir davon einfach so wenig wie möglich, so und den Rest schneiden wir
ab im Seitenschneider, so, eine Runde Lützchen dran, und jetzt sollte das, wenn ich Glück
habe, genau, da durchpassen, Pog, Funst, jetzt kann ich fest, das klappt wirklich, das hätte
ich gar nicht gedacht, ups, jetzt habe ich es wieder rausgesucht, guckt euch mal an,
das kann ich einfach hier durchstecken jetzt, hier, vorne das Ding, ihr seht das kaum, weil
das so klein ist, ich weiß, kann man jetzt einfach hier vorne reinstecken, und gut ist,
so, jetzt kann ich festlöten, gut, nice, das funktioniert ja wirklich, man kann auch
ein Stückchen zurechtbiegen, ok, nice, jetzt muss ich das noch irgendwie fest kriegen,
boah das wird eklig, ich glaube es ist fest, wartet mal, ja, das ist fest, nice, ok, eins
fehlt noch, eins fehlt noch, eins fehlt noch, also, guck mal, es ist der Plan, der Plan scheint
aufzugehen, wir haben jetzt dran, 3,3 Volt, RX, TX, TX ist ein bisschen wackelig, aber
hält trotzdem, muss ja danach eh wieder ab, jetzt brauche ich nur noch einen, und Ground,
so noch einen, nehmen wir noch einen blauen, das wird jetzt ein bisschen schwierig ranzubekommen,
weil da ist schon Lötz hin drinnen, trotzdem, probieren wir mal, probieren wir mal aus,
ich bin mal gespannt, ob sich das ganze danach dann wenigstens ordentlich flaschen lässt,
hoffe ich mal, mal gucken, ob ich das dran kriege, also das wird jetzt ein bisschen eklig,
das muss ich von unten machen auf jeden Fall, ok, so rum, neben, nicht neben das rote, sondern
ich muss neben, neben das schwarze muss ich, ok, das wird, boah das wird eklig, alter das
wird eklig da ranzukommen, muss ich gucken, dass ich nichts ablöte aus Versehen, ist das
ein CP2, das nicht, aber das da, ja das ist ein ganz normaler FTDI Adapter, und der Schnitt
von meiner Katz im Finger macht es nicht besser, ok, ist es dran, easy, nice, ok, fehlt nur
noch Crown, wir haben alles dran, wir haben alles dran, guckt mal, außer Crown, wir haben
3,3 Volt, guckt mal das rote haben wir, 3,3 Volt, ne man sieht es jetzt hier nicht richtig,
wir haben 3,3 Volt, einen frei, einen frei, GPIO 0, RX CX Ground, fehlt plus noch Crown,
und Crown kann ich von unten wahrscheinlich relativ easy dran machen, nehmen wir nochmal
den schwarzen, da bin ich mal gespannt jetzt, ob sich das gleich flashen lässt, sehr, sehr
gespannt, ob das funktioniert, da muss ich den Raspberry Pi gleich dran machen, und hoffen,
dass das alles erkannt wird und funktioniert, ja das ist ja scheiße so, was ist denn das
hier, nicht schön, so ist es besser, ich muss mir eine Brille holen für sowas Leute, ich
bin zu alt, ohne Scheiß ich sehe das schlecht mittlerweile, so ultra kleines Zeug, in welchem
Store nutzt du für so Elektrogeräte, meistens Aliexpress, aber auch Banggood, hat ja gerade
der Chat schon geschrieben, aber auch oftmals ganz einfach bei Amazon, wenn es was günstiges
gibt, ok, wo muss ich dran, ganz in die Ecke, das sollte sich doch machen lassen, jetzt
können wir nämlich so rum, können wir nämlich so rum machen, haha, es ist dran, ok Leute
wir haben alles dran, gucken, lass mal kurz schauen, dass ich keine Brücke oder so drin
hab, gucken wir mal, let's go, ja, gucken wir mal, dass ich das alles richtig hab, also,
von unten schaut ok aus, von oben schaut eigentlich auch ok aus, also, dann wollen
wir doch mal, was natürlich ziemlich pepega von mir war, dass ich den Kram nicht erst
am FTDI-Dings festgelötet hab, jetzt muss ich noch mal gucken, wo es hier dran muss
auf der Seite, das war richtig Pepega-Style, ja, wahrscheinlich werde ich jetzt nämlich
den Kram wieder aus Versehen abreißen von hier, weil ich nicht aufpasse, ich kenn mich,
ich kenn mich.
Ok, so, jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, dass ich das jetzt richtig hier dran mache, also,
das ist einfach, der rote ist 3,3 Volt, welcher Lözin schmeckt am besten, das ist der Credo,
das ist der mit dem fetten Kapperavatar auf Twitter, den Name kann ich mir aus welchen
Gründen auch immer merken, ja, so, dann schauen wir mal, also wir brauchen 3,3 Volt, 3,3 Volt
brauchen wir, wir brauchen, was ist denn RXL und TXL, keine Ahnung, Ground brauchen wir,
Ground ist hier unten, Ground ist hier unten, ich mein, ich hab nur RX, TXD und TX, wat,
ich glaub, ich muss das hier vorne, ich glaub, ich muss das hier vorne dran machen, lass
mal kurz die Pin Belegung checken, das ist ein FTDI 232, FTDI 232, RXD, ach, das ist
data, oder, RXD, TXD, vermute ich jetzt mal, oder für was soll das sonst stehen, mach mal
vor, was mit Svel zu machen, ja, ich mach die ganze Zeit schon öfters was mit Svel,
okay, weiter im Text, RX, TX, also ich werd jetzt, ich werd jetzt erst mal, scheiß drauf,
ich löte jetzt erst mal 3,3 Volt dran, das war blöd, dass ich das so, dass ich das so
rumgemacht hab, richtig, richtig pepega, das hätt ich andersrum machen sollen, 3,3 Volt
ist dran, jetzt brauchen wir noch Ground, und wir brauchen Ground noch für GPIO 0, das
heißt, theoretisch, ich kann die beiden schwarzen Kabel, beide an Ground machen, wenn ich das
jetzt richtig seh, was wird zusammengebastelt, das ist ein Schalter für USB Geräte, den
muss ich ja mit Custom Firmware flashen, dass es funktioniert, und ich versuche grade Pins
dran zu bekommen, dass es funktioniert, das gar nicht so easy ist, wie ich mir das vorgestellt
hab, das ist ein, genau, das ist ein USB zu Serial Chip im Endeffekt, okay, so wie krieg
ich denn jetzt den Kram da dran, das ist richtig, ich räu dich, alter, wahrscheinlich brech
ich's gleich ab oder so, ich muss das beides an Ground kriegen, was davon ist denn jetzt,
Ground ist hier vorne, da kommt man ja mal super beschissen hin, kann ich den Kram nicht
erstmal zusammenlöten hier, das wackelt schon, ich seh's schon, äh, hat das hier vorne
nicht einen Ground vielleicht, doch hier unten ist auch ein Ground, ja vielleicht sogar sinnvoller,
der Zweck ist dann nur, ja, das ist nur zum Flashen, genau, das ist nur zum Flashen, mein,
ich muss den Kram irgendwie an Ground kriegen, so da dran irgendwie, das ist doof, kann ich
das hier dran machen, da komm ich besser hin, boah, was ein Gefuddel, man, aber das hätte
ich vorher machen müssen, jetzt komm ich nicht mal richtig, ich hätte den Kram da dran machen
müssen, bevor ich ihn da dran mache, egal, jetzt können wir nicht aufgeben, jetzt, das
muss jetzt weiter gemacht werden, kann ich den Kram vielleicht irgendwie, ok, das erste
ist dran, ich mein, die Kabel lassen sich halt mega schnell löten, das ist ja, kann
ich das nicht einfach da dran wickeln oder drum wickeln, haben wir nicht noch ein Ground,
hier ist auch noch ein Ground, oh, perfekt, noch, noch ein Ground, ah, man, boah, ist
das aber nicht, Dex-Kram, so, das rutscht, das rutscht, das rutscht, das rutscht, das
rutscht und macht, so, ist dran, ok, so, wir brauchen jetzt noch zwei Kabel, dann haben
wir's, wir müssen noch RX, TX dran kriegen, noch RX und TX, dann haben wir's, die Sache
ist plus die, was ist was, das sind beides blaue Kabel, das ist nicht das Problem, aber,
also, TX, TX ist der an, auf, an der, an der Seite, also das da, ok, jetzt muss ich's
vertauschen, Leute, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, muss ich, genau, TX muss
an RX und RX muss an TX, genau, genau, genau, so hab ich, so hab ich das nämlich auch in
Erinnerung, ich weiß bloß nicht, welcher von, welcher ist, also TX ist der an Ground,
das heißt, TX, TX ist der an Ground, also muss der da dran, der muss dann da dran, machen
wir doch einfach mal hier, ok, ok, der an Ground ist der hier, der an Ground muss den,
sondern machen wir den hier zuerst, der da, der da, boah, ist das dann gefuddelt, meine
Güte, Alter, what the fuck, what the fuck, ob ich das dran kriege, ohne was abzureißen,
ich bin aber gespannt, ob ich das dran bekomme, ok, ich mach mal wieder Fullscreen, ob ich
das dran bekomme, auf, komm her, ok, gut, ok, so, also, der, wo hab ich gesagt muss
was dran, das ist RX und der auf, der neben Ground muss an RX, ok, der neben Ground ist,
der da, der da, der muss dahin, wie auch immer ich das gescheitert hinfuddelt, aber ok,
irgendwie, irgendwie muss das, boah, shit, keck wait, Alter, soll das funktionen, wie
kriege ich denn das jetzt hin, Moment, ich muss da irgendwas drauflegen, ja, da müsste
Neurochirurg sein, ja, da müsste irgendwas, kriege ich denn das da jetzt dran, hab ich
hier, warte mal, hab ich hier unten nicht was, RXL, TXL, RXS, TXD, ja, das muss ich
hier vorne dran machen, boah, ich mach den anderen erst, erst, erst den da, ok, boah,
das ist ja abadig, ah, MonkaS, wie soll denn das funktionieren jetzt, das rutscht, ok,
wir müssen da irgendwas drauflegen, ich mein, das muss ja nur kurz dran zum Flaschen, dann
ist wieder gut, ok, linkshändig löten, auch ok, ok, es ist dran, es ist nicht schön dran,
was war das, irgendwas hab ich runter geschmissen gerade, habt ihr gesehen, was das runtergefallen
ist irgendwo, hab ich irgendwo was runter geschmissen, irgendwo ist was runtergefallen
gerade, hab ich im Hintergrund gehört, so, und das letzte Kabel Leute, das letzte Kabel,
dahin, dahin, machen jetzt, wisst ihr was, wir machen da jetzt so ein Haken rein, guck
mal, machen so ein Haken rein, perfekt, oder auch nicht, Monka, MonkaS, ok, ich glaub ich
hab's, Leute, ich hab's, es ist dran, es ist dran, so, ok, jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob das
funktioniert, das wird, ob das was wird, ah, can't wait man, ok, Raspberry Pi ist am Start,
switch, switch, muss den switch einschalten, wird das nix, so, Raspberry Pi am Start, das
ist jetzt zwar nicht schön hier, aber ich muss das alles irgendwie auf den Tisch kriegen,
so, Raspberry Pi am Start, den, Moment, ich brauch ein Stromkabel für den Raspberry Pi,
ah, fuck, Alter, so viel Kabelstells, man, hab ich hier, ja, hier ist ein Stromkabel,
hier ist auch noch ein Stromkabel, ok, ich hab ein Stromkabel für den Raspberry Pi gefunden,
ne, hab ich nicht, ich brauch ein ordentliches Stromkabel, weil der Raspberry Pi läuft von
SSD und damit der von SSD läuft, brauch ich ein ordentliches Stromkabel und nicht diesen
billy shit, hier, das da brauch ich, hab ich noch mehr, was ist das hier, was hab ich hier
liegen, ich hab so viel Kabel hier, das ist der Wahnsinn, ne, das sind alles Mikro-USB,
ich brauch ein USB-C, Max, Max, wo ist dein USB-C, USB-C, hier ist kein USB-C, hier ist
kein USB-C, USB-C, ok, dann, boah, das ist ja abartig, ich muss das Kabel an der Kamera
umstecken, weil ich brauch jetzt ein USB-C Stecker, ok, USB-C, Raspberry Pi, Gibi, geht
der an, er ist an, ok, boah, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, also, weiß jemand, ob die
Qualität von Fotos und der Zip leidet, nein, die bleibt gleich, was brauchst du in Raspberry
Pi Zero für meine Kamera, du meinst den normalen Raspberry Pi, den ich hier hab, den brauch
ich jetzt zum Flashen, nein, die Qualität von Zip, wenn du es entpackst danach, was
du ja eh machen musst, sonst kannst du die Bilder nicht sehen, es sieht genau so aus
wie vorher, so, Pi Add, was hat der Raspberry Pi jetzt für eine IP, Moment, Mikro Tick Router,
IP, DHCP Server, Leases, Pi, wo ist der Raspberry Pi, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ich finde den Raspberry Pi in meinem DHCP gerade nicht, warum nicht, hat er, hat er
nicht, hat er nicht gescheit gebootet, oder was, doch, doch, sieht eigentlich so aus
als hätte er gesch- ach, ne. Raspberry Pi- ach hier ist er. Hier ist er. Ich hab ihn.
Ich hab ihn, hier. SSH-Pi-Add-S. Zudo. Das ist den, den wir das letzte Mal anhatten. Okay,
also ESP-Tool. ESP-Tool zum Flaschen. Brauchen wir das? Okay. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob sich das Ding flaschen lässt, Alter. Also, wer jetzt erst dazu kommt, ist das Ziel ist,
hier oben dieses Ding zu flaschen. Ich hab alles dran gelötet. Ich hoffe, ich hab's richtig gemacht.
Und den schließen wir gleich bei USB an. Aber erstmal brauch ich TASMOTA-Bin. Brauche ich die
aktuellste Firmware. Tja, 4MB passt da bestimmt nicht drauf. TASMOTA-Bin, hier. Weget. Alles klar,
das ist das Richtige. Okay, jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit. Wir müssen den Gramm flaschen.
Also, USB dran. Ich mach mal USB 2, wer weiß, was sonst für Probleme gibt. Und jetzt stöpsel ich
diesen Adapter hier dran. Und wenn wir Glück haben, blinkt das jetzt auch gleich. Wenn es
blinkt, ist schon mal gut. Weil dann, dann hat's Strom und alles. Äh, wie rum? Warte mal, ist das
kein Mikro-USB? Leute, das ist kein Mikro-USB. Das ist ein, das ist ein fucking Mini-USB noch.
Mini-U, meine Güte, wo hab ich denn Mini-USB? Pepega-Shit, Alter. Hab ich hier noch Mini-USB?
Äh, Mikro-USB? Mini-USB, man, was braucht denn sowas, man? Fuck. Ich hab kein, ich hab doch irgendwo
ein Mini-USB. Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz gucken. Ich hab, ich weiß, dass ich einen hab. Was ist
das hier? Mini-USB, USB. Ah, hier hab ich einen. Hier hab ich einen. Mal kurz, muss schon mal kurz
entwirren. Das Kabel liegt hier schon seit zwei Schaltjahren rum und braucht keiner. Kabelchamp.
Hier. Ich hab noch eins gefunden. Du brauchst Ablenkung. Unsere Pacht soll um das Fünffache
angehoben werden. Off-Fields-Batman. So, Leute, ich hab noch was gefunden. Das Ding ist uralt.
Ich mach mal meinen Lötkol aus, by the way. Der schaltet sich übrigens von alleine runter.
So, mal gucken, ob es jetzt blinkt. Es hat geblinkt, Leute. Es ist übrigens ziemlich doof,
dass ich das auf Metall lege, fällt mir gerade auf. Ich sollte das nicht auf Metall legen.
Auf Metall legen ist immer Kurzschlusschamp. Leute, es blinkt, es blinkt. Das Problem ist,
das Kabel fällt runter. So, es blinkt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es blinken... Guckt mal,
seht ihr, es blinkt, es blinkt. Blinken ist gut. Blinkchamp. ESP-Tool... Warte mal, ESP-Tool...
Aufrufen. Wie funktioniert das nochmal? ESP-Tool-Port-Erase-Flash. Brauchen wir nicht...
Ja, wir können es mal ausprobieren. Wir können mal Erase-Flash machen und gucken,
ob das prinzipiell funktioniert. Prager! Prager! Seht nicht so gut aus, oder?
Aber der blinkt. Blinken ist prinzipiell doch gut. Fail to connect. Moment. Moment. Auf welchen
Serial-Port muss ich überhaupt? Nein, nein, nein. E-DEF-TTY-USB. Nee, ist es nicht minus E,
minus minus Port. Nee, ich muss GPIO 0 auf Ground machen und das habe ich gemacht. Ich
muss das Ding mal umdrehen. Also, ich mein... Guckt mal, dadurch, dass das Ding blinkt,
daher wissen wir doch schon mal, es ist auf jeden Fall Ground und 3,3 Volt richtig dran,
oder? Anders kann es ja nicht gehen. Machen wir noch mal raus. Noch mal rein. Nein,
nein, es ist TTY-USB 0, sieht man ja hier. RXTX vertauscht. Ja, habe ich, aber vielleicht
haben es die China-Chinesen auch vertauscht. Kann es sein, dass der nicht in Flash-Modus
bootet? Dass der nicht in Flash-Modus geht? Okay, wie kann ich ihn einstellen, was ich
für eine Firmware-Flasche hier. 0,0 TAS-MOTA-BIN. TAS-MOTA-BIN. Nee. Bright Flash. Bright Flash.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht. Ja, woran könnte das jetzt liegen? Gucken wir uns das nochmal
genau an. Nee, nee, da macht nichts. Shit. Okay, gucken wir uns das nochmal genau an.
So. Ground und so, das passt alles. Ich mache mal kurz das Ding hier weg.
Moment, ihr seht nichts. Das Kabel ist kaputt. Nee, das glaube ich nicht, dass das Kabel kaputt
ist. Also. Ground ist auf jeden Fall dran. Kontakt miteinander hat hier auch nichts.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Was habe ich denn da gemacht? Ich habe, Moment, ich habe
die Kabel vertauscht. Wie geht dann sowas? Cack you, Alter. Wie geht dann sowas? Wait
a minute. Ich habe, ich habe GPIO 0. Ich habe GPIO 0 an Rx oder so. Wait a minute, jetzt
bin ich verwirrt. Was habe ich gemacht? Moment. Ja. Ich habe GPIO 0. Okay, das muss ich, das
muss ich anders machen. Das da, das was ich an Ground gemacht habe hier unten, guck mal,
was da, was ich da an Ground gelötet habe, ist eigentlich, ist eigentlich Tx oder so,
ist eigentlich Rx. Oh man, MonkaS, ich blicke nicht mal durch. Was habe ich gemacht? Rx,
Rx. Okay, okay, das muss ich, da muss ich das schon mal weg machen. Das können wir
zum Glück alles auf der Seite erledigen. Nee, das ist Ground, das ist richtig. Also,
mal Lötcoil wieder anmachen. So, also das ist falsch. Das ist falsch. Das hier, das
hier ist Rx oder was ich falsch gemacht habe. Ich habe Rx falsch gemacht. Das heißt, ich
muss den an Tx dran machen, an den dritten Pin. Ja. Boah, ich bin blöd. Ich muss, ich
muss die zwei vertauschen hier. Die zwei muss ich vertauschen. In der Hoffnung, ich kriege
das irgendwie ab. Passt. Vielleicht habe ich Glück. Oh beinahe. Ah, mein Finger wird
blöd. So, und das muss jetzt da dran. Und danach ist Praege, Chat. Chat, ich brauche
Praege im Chat, ob das jetzt funktioniert. So, ich habe den Kram vertauscht, jetzt probieren
wir es nochmal aus. Praege, Praege im Chat, Leute, Praege. Den da. Ich hoffe, jetzt stimmt
alles. Ich sehe noch nicht einen Praege. Bevor ich zumindest einen Praege im Chat habe,
mache ich das nicht. Was macht der Gerät, der gelötet wird? Das ist ein USB Schalter,
damit kannst du Geräte, USB Geräte ein ausschalten. Ok. Zack. Ok. Es blinkt noch alles, es blinkt
noch. Und jetzt leuchtet es auch durchgängig. Jawoll. Bam. Flashke. Der Flashchamp ist am
Start. Ich hole mal kurz mein iPad, dass ich das Ding einrichten kann. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Der Flashchamp ist am Start. Ok, nice. Leute, haben wir da jetzt wirklich zwei Stunden für
gebraucht? Sehe ich das richtig? Wobei, ich habe eine Stunde geschwätzt vorher, oder?
Ich habe eine Stunde vorher geschwätzt. Ok. Der sollte jetzt Rebooten gleich. Ah, Moment,
Moment. Nein, nein, nein. Wartet mal. Ich muss Ground ablöten wieder, damit das Ding
ordentlich bootet. Das ist ziemlich pepega dieses Setup, aber ok. So und jetzt sollte
ich ein, jetzt sollte ich ein Tasmota, Tasmota Access Point bekommen in den Settings. Moment,
Wifi. Tasmota Access Point. Aha. Sehr schön. Funktioniert. So und jetzt muss ich WLAN Info
eingeben. Ich muss mal kurz mein WLAN Passwort mir auf dem zweiten Monitor aus dem Passwort
save suchen. Ok. Ihr seht gleich wieder was, gleich seht ihr nämlich ein Web Interface
von dem Ding. Save. Trying to connect Tasmota Device. Schau mal kurz in meinen Router. Der
sollte sich jetzt eigentlich connect, ist es das hier schon? 60, 111? Ist es das schon?
60, 111, das müsste es sein. Also angeblich, angeblich ist das das Tasmota Ding. Hat gerade
eben eine IP bekommen. Das müsste es eigentlich sein. Aber ich versuche das gerade zu öffnen
auf dem zweiten Monitor, das funktioniert hinten und vorne nicht. Aber ich könnte so
ganz einfach testen, ob es das ist. Ich ziehe den Strom raus und dann geht der Ping aus.
Ja, das ist es, guckt. Das ist es, Ping ist aus. Jetzt mache ich es wieder an. Ja. Ja.
Da ist es wieder. Das ist das auf jeden Fall. Also 60. Warum geht denn das Tasmota Zeug
jetzt nicht auf? 200 Ping wie Call of Duty Lobby. Zu irgendwelchen Gründen ist der Chat.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt den Chat offen? Da ist es doch. Nice. Ok. So Chat, jetzt muss
ich euch mal ganz kurz ausmachen, was einstellen. Ihr dürft jetzt nicht gucken.
Es ist so dunkel, ja. Es nennt sich Dark Mode. Ok, geschafft. Weiter geht's.
Gut, wir haben es geschafft, Leute. Jetzt kann man USB-Geräte ein ausschalten mit.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das switcht, wenn ich das jetzt switchen lasse. Keine Ahnung,
ich höre da nichts. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht stimmen die Relays ja auch noch gar nicht.
Lass mal kurz schauen. Tasmota muss ich suchen. Tasmota Templates. Das da brauchen wir. Das
da brauchen wir. Also Tasmota Config Module. Nee, Other glaube ich. Oza. Activate. Was,
wer ist der Psychopath mit dem dicken Kappa Bild auf Twitter? Hä? Der war gerade im Chat
noch. Ihr steckt unter einer Decke. Ich habe euch durchschaut. So, jetzt haben wir den Kram
hier. Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob das schaltet. Ja, seht ihr das? Guckt mal. Jetzt ist grün.
Jetzt ist rot. Sieht man nicht richtig. Wartet mal, wartet mal. So, passt auf. Grün, rot.
Sieht man aus? Kunst. Max, wie viele Geräte, das ist eine interessante Frage, das weiß
ich gar nicht. Max, wie viele Geräte sind inzwischen aktuell bei dir im WLAN unterwegs
und aufgeteilt? Das kann ich dir sagen. Wie viele Geräte? Ich habe meinen DHCP Server
hier gerade irgendwo offen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Mikrotik eine Gesamtanzahl anzeigt. DHCP,
vergebene DHCP Adressen. 72. Also Mikrotik sagt gerade 72 Items in meinem DHCP. Also
müssten es wohl ungefähr 72 Geräte sein. Allerdings über alle Netzwerke. Über alle
Netzwerke verteilt. Nicht nur WLAN. Also auch interne Geräte. Also alles. Von der Switch
bis zum Shield, zum Desktop, bis zum Server, bis zu WLAN Geräten. 72. Wohlgemerkt nur
Geräte, die DHCP bekommen. Es gibt auch ein paar Geräte, die statische IPs haben. Also
sagen wir mal 80. Sagen wir mal 80. Umgefähr. Ich könnte im Unify Controller gucken. Ja,
aber da habe ich das Passwort gerade nicht. Also wie gesagt, der DHCP Server sagt gerade
72. Davon sind nicht alle Leases aktiv. Oben sind ein paar nicht abgeholt. Aber nachdem
da auch IPs drin sind, die nicht drin sind, die statisch sind, ich würde mal sagen, bleiben
wir bei 72. Bleiben wir bei 72. Ja, kommt wahrscheinlich ganz gut hin. So. Ja, da ist
alles drin. Von Raspberry Pis bis ESPs bis Steckdosen bis Shelly Relays. Da kommt man
relativ schnell mal hin. So. Also. Leute. Wir waren erfolgreich. Seht ihr das? Seht
ihr das? Grün. Rot. Ein- und Ausschalten geht. Kannst du den USB Stick jetzt auch per
Netzwerk steuern? Das ist doch per Netzwerk. Oder wie? Hä? Das ist doch übers Netzwerk.
Oder meinst du, ob das Ding, ja, das Ding hat eine HTTP API und über MQTT kannst du
das auch steuern? Richtig. Also ich könnte das jetzt in meine Heimat Automatisierung
einbinden, die ich euch jetzt hier aber nicht zeigen kann. Wollen wir mal was einstecken?
Wollen wir mal was einstecken? Und dann ein- und ausschalten? Können wir machen. Muss
ich mir- Ich brauche nur mein USB Gerät dafür jetzt. Also stöpseln wir das erstmal aus
dem Raspberry Pi aus. Ich brauche ein USB Gerät. Wo man ganz klar sieht, dass es an
oder aus ist. Wo habe ich denn mein USB Tester? Da sieht man das wunderbar. Sekunde Leute.
Wo habe ich meinen USB Tester? Ich habe einen richtig nice USB Tester. Die Sache ist Plastil,
den verwende ich so selten. Kurz checken hier, ob der nicht vielleicht hier drin ist.
Da ist er. Ich habe ihn. Ich wusste doch, dass der da ist. Hier. USB Tester.
Also USB Tester, stöpseln wir da rein. Jetzt bräuchte ich eine USB Verlängerung. USB Verlängerung.
Sekunde. Ich muss eine USB Verlängerung haben. Ich habe doch alles da. Ah, so entspannende
Musik, das mag ich. Ich muss mal kurz entkabeln schnell. So. B Verlängerung entkabelt. Entwirrt.
Ok, also stecken wir es mal ein. Ok, es ist aus. Guckt, es ist aus. Aus. Es pingt. Es
pingt auch. Alles klar. Und jetzt mache ich an. Bäm. Und der USB Tester geht an. Seht
ihr? Achtung, aus. An. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
An Rui Deng 5,1 4V USB jawoll
Funktioniert Nur die Farbe sind geflippt vielleicht soll
das sein Rot ist an und grün ist aus ja das stimmt
wie viel leistung kann das ding schalten was ist ein maximum für usb 5 volt 2
ampere ich weiß es gar nicht also ich glaube nicht dass der quick charge ready ist
nee ich habe keine empfehlung dafür das einzige was ich mir mal vor einer weile
gekauft habe sind halt sind halt diese dinger so kleine rollen mit ach so ich
sehe da gar nichts das was ich mir gekauft habe vor einer weile ist halt
das hier diese packung bei amazon sind jetzt nicht alle sachen drin hier gehören
auch blaue blaue schwarze und und so dabei hat sie irgendwie keine ahnung 5
euro oder so bei amazon hat das pack gekostet das reicht für mich ewig das
sind aber auch keine 500 meter rollen ja bis 50 watt auf 12 volt ja gut ob das
darüber gut funktioniert weiß ich nicht die sind die sind schon die sind schon
aus stunden was eventuell enkrock remote zugänglich machen was mein usb schalter
die demarie bestimmt nicht remote zugänglich
aliexpress sagt das ding kann 20 volt da habe ich meine zweifel aber ok ich habe
jetzt ich habe jetzt nix also der usb tester kann keine kein quickchart
zumindest
so ja dass das funktioniert ich bin ich bin begeistert gibt es einen tipp für
eine gute lötstation ja da habe ich einen tipp kommt darauf an was ausgehen
willst also ich habe hier eine ja ich habe leider den ganzen den ganzen tisch
voll man sieht nicht also ich habe eine eine
erser icon nano da guck kann man übrigens mal ausmachen
das ist die station das ist die station mein gott es sieht ja aus leute das ist
die station und das hier ist das ist der lötkolben dazu was halt bei dem wirklich
sehr sehr nice ist du hast halt ein sehr flexibles kabel und der lötkolben ist
klein vergleichen mit einem daumen hast auswechselbare spitzen und man das nicht
unbedingt auswechseln sollte wenn er gerade heiß ist und ist wirklich wirklich
nahe ich bin damit echt zufrieden habe ich gedacht vor ein paar jahren ich
kaufe mir mal was ordentliches dass ich nicht immer hier am rum wurschteln bin
mit so billig kacke
das einzige problem bei dem ding ist das ist nicht ganz billig
schauen wir mal erser icon nano
das koste halte bis sie was es übrigens teurer geworden im vergleich zu dem wo
ich es gekauft habe minus 16 prozent ja wer es glaubt ich glaube ich habe 179
oder so dafür bezahlt
kennt ihr mal glühbirnen die man mit wled flaschen kann ja so schiena so schien
er sp basierte da musste aber halt glück haben dass du noch welche findest die
noch ota flashbar sind
und an ich bin begeistert das funktionieren da bleibt jetzt eigentlich
noch eine sache zu tun das wieder abzulöten und in seine packung zu packen
so dazu mache ich mal kurz hier ein bisschen ein bisschen platz weil ich
blicke hier nicht mehr durch das zu viel ich meine guckt euch das mal an
what the hell
raspberry pi aus
weg damit um die kabel muss auch raus
du du du du du du du du du du du du das ist aber sehr stabil hier
wieder kaum raus
so gut dann löten wir den kram ja noch mal schnell ab das sollte ja relativ easy
gehen ach ja und übrigens eine sache die mega nice ist an dieser loot station
guckt mal die heizt ziemlich schnell erkennt man das display die heizt wirklich
ziemlich schnell auf guck mal ich mache jetzt an
so fertig das geht wirklich sehr schön zackig fünf sekunden oder so ist die
auf voller pulle das ist sehr nice
ich muss ich muss jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen nicht ich will jetzt ich will
jetzt nicht nicht kaputt machen noch auf den letzten drücker ich habe es
abgerissen lull so viel also das kabel nicht nicht irgendwie sonst was
schlimmes ich habe seine kabel gerade abgerissen naja
wenn ich den kram jetzt noch raus bekommen würde
ok nice gut
gai zahl zwar die letzten jahren nicht unter 190 euro da dann habe ich vielleicht
auch falsch im kopf aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich habe weniger
als also definitiv weniger bezahlt als das was jetzt bei amazon ist und ich bin
mir auch relativ sicher dass ich weniger bezahlt habe als 200 euro und ich habe
im hinterkopf irgendwas von wie 179 oder so was ich gucke mal ob gerade bei
amazon kann ich mich bei amazon einloggen
hallo maximilian oder nämlich bin ich hier bei amazon eingeloggt anmelden
ne ich bin ja nicht bei amazon eingeloggt 2017 war sie um die 140 ja wie gesagt ich
habe die schon ein paar jahre ich habe die ja schon ein paar jahre
wo ist das gehäuse hin da ok dann machen wir das jetzt mal rein und da gucken wir
abschließen ob alles funktioniert hat jemanden plan wie rum das drinne war ok
es muss so rum drin gewesen sein weil da ist der knopf
so so muss das so muss das eigentlich gewesen sein
da sieht man die inflation ja ja
also irgendwie passt es nicht mehr wie kann es sein dass es jetzt nicht mal
richtig zu geht wie ist das wie ist das möglich kann auch gar nicht sein wie
warum geht es ist immer richtig zu
was ist das aha man muss einfach nur möglichst feste drauf drücken dann geht es mir dazu
gut das ist zu jetzt testen was noch mal abschließen ob alles noch funktioniert was braucht man
alles um so ein teil zu flaschen naja du musst an die pins in dran dran löten das heißt
du brauchst du brauchst ein paar kabels du brauchst löten du brauchst den f td f tdi adapter das
ist ein usb auf serial um dann dein esp image zu flaschen raspberry pi ist auch nicht schlecht
zum flaschen wobei du es auch ohne probleme per usb an einem desktop pc flaschen kannst
ok testen was mal abschließend noch ob alles jetzt noch funktioniert ich habe wieder abgelötet ich
habe zugemacht so blink blink blink einstöpseln erst mal gucken ob der knopf funktioniert
alle da verbindet sich noch ok da kann ich kann ich werden erst mal warten bis
er sich wlan technisch verbunden hat wlan ist doch da ok der knopf geht der knopf
der knopf geht guckt sogar sogar der knopf man sieht dass hier unten der da der knopf
knopf aus knopf an der knopf geht und hier und hier funktioniert es auch ok operation
erfolgreich würde ich sagen wie heißt das rote teil noch mal ist ein f tdi adapter die
gibt es in zig zig ausführungen schon ziemlich günstig f tdi musst du mal gucken da gibt es
auch welche die glaube ich standardmäßig unter windows unterstützt werden ohne extra treiber
es gibt bestimmt auch komfortabel komfortabler als diese dinger das ist übrigens brutals teuer
ich habe einen fünfer pack gekauft für den preis vor ein paar jahren mein güte ist das
teuer geworden zwei china chinesen ftd c 90 ich habe einen fünfer pack gekauft ihr wisst
ja ich glaube immer noch fünfer packs es gibt auch fertige gleich mit usb aber das ist nicht so
schön besser mit usb also das ist ganz schön teuer geworden alles wirklich teuer kann man
nicht sagen an gleich rot wie kann man das ändern das kann man wahrscheinlich ändern in
dem man auf konfig module geht ich hätte jetzt gedacht dass ich in der led habe
konfig template ach das suche ich war schon richtig ich hätte gedacht ich habe jetzt eine led weiß
was auch sein kann es kann auch sein dass die led gar nicht über den microcontroller gesteuert
wird sondern direkt on board genau kein patschi wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich kann ich das nicht
ändern wahrscheinlich ist es immer so also auch auch auch die fall nicht jetzt nur nach dem
flaschen also wahrscheinlich ist immer aus grün und rot an kann man nichts machen china china
chinesen farb encoding keine chance ist es hat hardcoded sozusagen oder hart codiert wie die
die deutsch fans das sagen hat code ist es ist hart codiert ist das weiß ich mal hart codiert
ist sondern hart hart wired ist das hart hart verkabelt wie wie soll man das auf deutsch überhaupt
sagen direkt verkabelt ja aber seht ihr es tut ich bin ich bin begeistert ja klick aus klick an
ich meine wie wir einfach eineinhalb stunden gebraucht haben ne zweieinhalb stunden jetzt
dafür eigentlich wollte ich ich habe es euch am anfang eigentlich wollte ich noch viel eine
sache habe ich noch wie ist denn die default einstellung gehen wir mal von aus es ist an wenn
jetzt das strom weg fliegt so chat was meint ihr wenn jetzt das strom weg war und ich jetzt
wieder anstöpsel geht es dann standardmäßig wieder an oder bleibt es erstmal aus ich glaube
ich weiß die antwort weil die haben das motor glaube ich mittlerweile den default sinnvoll
angepasst ist verdrahtet genau also ich glaube es bleibt aus weil ich bilde mir ein das kannst du
konfigurieren ja ich weiß aber ich bilde mir ein die standard settings sind mittlerweile dass
es erstmal aus bleibt beim strom an nein ist nicht so es geht direkt wieder an das kannst
das kann man das motor aber ändern anscheinend ist hier standardmäßig tatsächlich so dass
er sich die letzten den letzten state merkt weil guckt jetzt ist aus und ich mache strom raus und
strom rein und jetzt bleibt er bleibt er aus anscheinend merkt dass ich wirklich den letzten
state ok was auch immer ich habe übrigens alles oder an subs übersehen wenn wir gerade dabei
sind den haben wir noch an der stelle so hat es gehabt der puzzelmeister hat subscribt ganz
viele follower am start mysterion auch am start take viagra danke für die ganzen subs übrigens
leute ich habe gehört prime subscriben ist immer noch kostenlos sollte euch der content gefallen
power on state achte voll ist safe last state tatsächlich ich habe gedacht dass der default
mittlerweile standardmäßig aus ist lego vogel danke für den sub ich habe ich nicht übersehen
weil ich jetzt schon fertig bin nur der letzte warst dana force danke für den sub so muss das
sein nur eine runde aquarium entspannen entspanntes ascii aquarium laufen lassen
via mehr muss mal kurz die kurz in in der home in der home automation geschichte die
bastellampe ausschalten jawoll bastellampe aus sieht mir nämlich bisschen zu hell so leute
eine runde am strand mit der passenden musik moment die passende musik ist das hier
wir können übrigens das aquarium auch klassisch machen
da könnte man eigentlich so ein 24 7 twitch stream draus machen oder ascii aquarium 24
7 einfach im hintergrund da ja da ja docks laufen und fullscreen
und fullscreen ascii aquarium das ist mindestens so entspannt wie bob ross oder
max ich verfolge dich schon seit ein paar jahren aber ich will eine fachinformatiker
ausbildung anfangen ja es werden aktuell mehr gebraucht denn je deine videos sind dafür
echt beruhigend beziehungsweise inspirieren das ist schon es haben viele leute schon geschrubst
es haben viele leute jetzt in den letzten letzten letzten paar jahren ja wo ich jetzt
auch auf twitch bin geschrieben dass ich sie irgendwie dazu influenced habe fachinformatiker
zu werden das war nie meine absicht ursprünglich aber im nachhinein gesehen finde ich finde
ich wirklich nice dass das bei soviel funktioniert hat
und ich mache mir morgen einen neuen stream wir brauchen einen guten wir brauchen einen
guten channelname ascii aquarium 24 versteht keiner wir brauchen einen guten channelname
für einen stream der den ganzen tag da ja da ja docks plus ascii aquarium streamt was
macht ein it systemtechniker keine ahnung kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an wo man gerade
ist habt ihr eine gute idee für einen stream aquarium ist auch auch zu ja peter agile ist
auf jeden fall der besitzer des channels ist nee irgendwas was man sich merken kann ascii
blub blub relaxing ascii oder sowas in der in der in der richtung relaxing ascii irgendwie
sowas den haus der ich dann immer wenn wir fertig sind im stream ja ja ja aquarium bob
floss tv das ist gut das finde ich nice ob floss tv oder bob floss tv
naja so ich nächste mal chat was ist der unterschied zwischen einem linux administrator oh nein
zwischen einem linux administrator und einem linux architekt tja das hängt so ein bisschen
davon ab was die jeweiligen unternehmen daraus machen also allein schon allein schon wenn
man mal linux weglässt ich meine der unterschied zwischen einem administrator und einem architekt
ist dass ein architekt sachen entwirft und naja baut ist jetzt falsch dass ein architekt
sachen entwirft und so im großen und ganzen die architektur eben plant und administrator
administriert das was da ist wobei das natürlich auch fließend ist das das kommt immer ein
bisschen davon ab was die jeweiligen unternehmen sich darunter vorstellen also klassischer
linux administrator ist zum beispiel außendienst ruft bei der hotline an sagt hilfe mir fehlen
zwei emails von gestern dann ruft die hotline beim linux administrator an und fragt ey guck
mal der außendienstler war so blöden hat mails ausversehen gelöscht kannst du die
wieder herstellen dann geht der linux administrator in das backup oder auf irgendeinen backup server
oder was auch immer und kopiert zwei mails rüber auf das live auf den live mail server
so das ist so eine sache was linux administrator machen würde ein architekt der hätte sich
ausgedacht wie das mail system funktioniert also wie viele backup server gibt es wie viele
live server gibt es wie wird das richtig skaliert das würde der architekt machen ich glaube
das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute beschreibung aber es ist natürlich fließend und ich würde
mal sagen ein guter linux architekt war wahrscheinlich vorher mal linux und ansonsten ob die da
studium studium studium sachen dafür voraussetzen oder nicht da will ich mal nicht so viel drauf
geben die meisten schreiben in ihren stellenanzeigen immer immer ganz ganz wild irgendwie sowas
von wegen studium aber meistens steht dann auch dabei oder vergleichbare erfahrung oder
sonst was wenn du jetzt irgendwann mal vor 10 15 20 jahre was auch immer eine ausbildung
gemacht hast und kennst dich super aus in dem bereich hast vielleicht auch schon bei manchen
architektursachen mitgemacht die suche der händlerigen leute können sich das gar nicht
aussuchen warum sollten sie irgendjemand nehmen nur weil er studiert hat wirst es dich der
vielleicht das unternehmen kennt der die infrastruktur kennt der die zusammenhänge kennt und erfahrung
hat und sich eignet wer bescheuert das nicht zu machen ich mein das heißt nicht dass dass
die personalabteilung nicht manchmal bescheuerte dinger macht das ist gar keine frage es gibt
da öfters sachen wo ich mich frage warum macht man das aber da wird wie sagt man so
schön das wird da wird auch nicht so heiß gegessen wie gekocht wird letztendlich zählt
das was du kannst beziehungsweise das was du für erfahrung hast zweifelsfall natürlich
dass du auch belegen kannst ich meine damit ist keine zertifikate oder so zertifikate
manche mögen es manche nicht dass es halt im zweifelsfall unter beweis stellen kannst
du plan hast muss was können und alles im endeffekt wurscht ob du mal vor 20 jahren
studiert hast oder vor 20 jahren ausbildung gemacht hast oder vor 15 jahren vor 10 jahren
das geht ja fast gar nicht mehr die haben mittlerweile so abgedrehte anforderungen teilweise wir
schreiben alles mal rein die wollen dann einen full stack cloud native dev sack bis ops entwickler
oder sowas am besten am besten soll er privat am besten soll er privat auch noch youtuber
und instagram influencer mit einer million abos sein und kostenlos werbesachen für die
firma machen was auch immer den alles vorschwebt ja keine ahnung man IT abteilung das stimmt
wir haben ja ich meine ich habe ja wie eine videoserie da drüber über bescheuerte stellenanzeigen
im endeffekt wobei da nicht nur bescheuerte stellenanzeigen drin sind sondern manchmal
auch ganz gute was machen eigentlich eigentlich die wie hießen die die ich letztens in dem
video gezeigt habe bei mir irgendwas mit pirate die haben noch sogar geantwortet suchen die
immer noch php piraten stellenanzeigen hier wie ist die pirate pirate pirate ship ist tatsächlich
gibt sie noch ok ok die suchen immer noch in frau structure engineers also ist im prinzip
immer noch die gleiche stellenanzeige moment die seite gibt es einfach noch den job gibt
es aber nicht mehr kann man auch machen die fand ich auch nicht schlecht ja ja das sind
viele total an der realität vorbei sind jetzt an den den was was ist denn ck ad zick zickert
was ist das russisch ach das ist eine kubernetes zertifizierung meine güle abkürzung please da
habe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht dran gedacht leute was ist gleich ihr wisst genau gleich
ist spät ja ich habe auch gerade schon nachgeguckt wusste das nicht muss ich muss mal kurz gucken
in die meld ob hetzner geantwortet hat jetzt hat mir heute eine mail geschrieben für sachen
die sie geplant haben 2022 so was sponsoring und werbung angeht aber in dem fall bin ich
nicht so wirklich daraus schlau geworden was sie eigentlich haben wollen keine antwort
bis jetzt sag mal max hast du schon einen smart tv geflasht nein das habe ich noch nie gemacht
und die meisten smart tvs lassen sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht so einfach flaschen und die nächste
frage ist was machst du damit also was willst du flaschen das einzige was mir einfallen
würde ist vielleicht bei manchen smart tvs ein also wenn das android zu sehr verkackt
ist was da drauf ist vielleicht nen nicht so geblutet das android drauf zu machen aber
was smart tvs ist das glaube ich schwierig auch was treiber und integration angeht ich
glaube smart tvs flaschen ist keine gute idee sagt jetzt mein bauchgefühl gemacht habe ich
so nicht aber ich kann es mir eben nicht ich kann es mir auch nicht vorstellen dass das
sinnvoll ist
ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht vor mein mein tv zu flaschen weil ich meine ich habe zwar
einen mit android tv ich habe hier irgendeinen warte mal wohnzimmer ich habe doch ein wohnzimmer
video gemacht wohnzimmer wo ist mein wohnzimmer video das ist überhaupt nicht mein wohnzimmer
hier das ist das wohnzimmer vom doktor kaboom was man hier sieht von vor keine ahnung 10
jahren oder so das bin ich übrigens mit noch mehr haren damals kratze lauert auf nicht
vorhandene mäuse das war meine das war die letzte man sieht aber nicht sonderlich viel
von der katz außer dass die schwarze so große augen hat wohnzimmer wie habe ich das video
denn genannt wohnzimmer setup das da so ich war ich habe zwar einen fernseh genau so ein
ich habe zwar einen fernseh mit android tv aber die sache ist die ich verwende den überhaupt
nicht die smart funktionen sieht man jetzt hier nichts android android tv genau ich habe
per hdmi mein schiel tv angeschlossen und ich verwende nicht eine smarte funktion des
fernsehs ich ich verwende den fernseh den hdmi input sonst nix was leben sie mit luft
ist das netz eigentlich installiert was für ein netz für die katze ja klar ist das netz
installiert guck mal hier sieht man das nicht ja da siehst du es guck hier ist das netz
von patate als es geschneit hat ist das netz also vor ein paar tagen vorgestern hat es
geschneit keck weight da habe ich auch aus dem penzler geguckt hat mir das hier gedacht
seit null watt ja jetzt das netz guck dass das netz ist ungefähr 2 2 und halben meter
hoch ist gespannt rechts zwischen dem haus links zwischen dem stahl und unten ist einfach
um so um so ein brett drum gewickelt das netz das hebt die auch nicht hoch ja und die
findet das nice die liegt jetzt mehrfach täglich da draußen rum seine arbeit hat
heute was rumgeschickt dass jeder wo es möglich ist ein tag ja so ein blödsinn wollen sie
bei uns auch machen also blödsinn meine ich ein tag ist mir deutlich zu wenig ein tag
die woche nach frankfurt fahren das ist ok das lasse ich mit mir machen mehr nicht ist
das eine art fluchtnetz oder eine hängematte das ist ein netz was extra gedacht ist für
sowas und zwar habe ich boy katzen netze habe ich mir sowas bestellt extra stark sowas
hier und netze ich habe mir so ein netz netze also ein großes netz bestellt und dann montage
artikel stahlseils jetzt und dann so ein stunden stahlseil das sei neben stahl und
haus und dann das netz drüber und unten drunter habe ich einfach ein brett drum gewickelt links
habe ich am links habe ich an der wand noch festgemacht mit ein paar kabelbindern da ist
sowas wo man das drumherum machen kann ja einziges problem ist rechts an der hauswand
preis nicht so teuer das kriegst du billiger hier 95 quadratmeter musst halt gucken was
du brauchst so stahlseile mit spannungs sachen und so kriegst du wahrscheinlich sogar noch
billiger einfach amazon stahlseil so beim kriegst du hier alles mögliche fix und fertig
15 meter ja leider sind viele viele management und gerade nicht mal untere so mittleres management
sondern oberes management einfach zu boomer dafür für mehr home office die brauchen irgendwie
die kontrolle vor ort über die leute vollkommen egal ob die leute im endeffekt unterm strich
sogar mehr arbeiten im home office das interessiert die alle nicht die denken sich dann einfach
nur leider das ist das ist glaube ich auch so ein ding in deutschland wir sind eh schon
nicht sonderlich fortschrittlich was sowas angeht und korona hat viele überrascht und
dazu gezwungen dass sie das machen weil es gab im endeffekt die auswahl pleite gehen
oder oder homeoffice machen und jetzt wo korona vorbei ist denken sie sich halt also korona
ist nicht vorbei sondern ihr wisst wie ich das meine wo man sich gedacht hat wo man sich
denkt offiziell korona ist vorbei obwohl es nicht vorbei ist denke ich will jetzt ja gut
da können wir die leute wieder antanzen lassen es hat funktioniert ja das interessiert die
aber nicht die sind einfach die sind einfach zu boomer mäßig im kopf unterwegs die müssten
mal etwas ihre zoomer seite bitte aktivieren sie sind einfach zu zu weit in der vergangenheit
aber es ist doch ganz einfach wenn die unternehmen nicht mit der zeit gehen dann rennen ihnen
die mitarbeiter weg das sieht man bei uns an ganz vielen stellen schon da weiß ich aus
erster hand und das sieht man deutschland weit gerade im it sektor es werden hände ringend
an allen ecken und enden werden leute gesucht und du findest leute wenn du leuten ordentliche
arbeitsbedingungen lieferst und die unternehmen die das nicht hinbekommen die müssen sich
nicht wundern wenn die leute dann einfach in den nächsten wenn die nächste frist ist
wenn du kündigen kannst einfach alle abhauen und das ist bei uns so und das höre ich auch
von vielen anderen von uns weiß ich aus erster hand aber ich hörs auch ihr habt sie auch
schon öfters im chat geschrieben und die gehen dann einfach dorthin wo sie sich besser
aufgehoben fühlen und bessere arbeitsbedingungen haben ganz einfach da muss es noch gar nicht
mal bedeuten viel mehr geld geben vielleicht gibt sogar ein bisschen weniger geld kann
ja alles sein selbst schuld wenn die leute ihn abhauen selbst schuld und geht es noch
geht es noch es geht noch ok also auch nichts kaputt gegangen jetzt wenn das ding fünf
minuten dann ist wenn seit corona fast durchgehend im homeoffice ja ich auch bei uns ist es auch
aktuell noch so aber es gab jetzt bei uns schon so eine so eine ankündigung dass auch
das corona jetzt ja offiziell vorbei ist und wir jetzt zu dem zurückkehren was quasi mit
unseren vorgesetzten besprochen war und ich habe vor einer weile schon mit meinem vorgesetzten
was besprochen das mache ich auch jetzt erst mal so weit und sollte wirklich irgendjemand
von mir mal wirklich verlangen dass ich wieder regelmäßig hingehe also was das regelmäßig
gehe regelmäßig nach wie vorhin dass ich wieder mehrfach die woche also mehr als ein
tag die woche nach frankfurt fahr das werde ich nicht machen also dann werde ich entweder
meine arbeitszeit weiter verkürzen so dass ich nur einmal die woche nach frankfurt fahren
muss oder ich suche mir was anderes was anderes suchen ist die letzte letzte möglichkeit will
ich eigentlich nicht ich finde es gar nicht schlechter wo ich jetzt bin aber sollte ich
da wieder vier drei oder vier tage die woche antanzen sollen dann könnt ihr vergessen
mache ich nicht ja das ist den das ist den boomer management doch vollkommen egal co2
emissionen als würde das großartig jucken das das einzige das einzige mal wenn ein der
boomer manager co2 emissionen juckt ist wenn die tochter gerade bei friday for future aktiv
ist und ihn nervt dann juckt ihn das und nicht weil es ihn wirklich juckt sondern weil ihm
seine tochter auf den keks geht ansonsten sind den co2 emission komplett egal ja früchte
korb ist natürlich der grund warum man auf die arbeit fahren sollte anstatt dem home
office zu bleiben übrigens sollte ich mal was sagen wenn man home office hat man kann
sogar selbst bestimmen ob man einen fruchtkorb hat oder nicht und man kann essen was man
will und wann man will und das wichtigste wisst ihr chat frage an euch mal gucken ob
ich es euch denke was meint ihr ist für mich das größte plus am ganzen home office neben
ausschlafen und sowas das was für mich ein riesen ein unglaubliches plus ist ruhe das
auch unterhose am pc mache ich nicht aber das auch kochen ja vielleicht ja auch keine
nervigen leute das auch aber es gibt einen punkt der wird immer vergessen mein klo richtig
hell ich erforscht mein klo mein eigenes klo ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie viel
lieber ich auf mein klo gehe als in irgendein auf auf irgendein klo auf der arbeit mein
klo ist absolut pock das ist das beste klo auf der welt und wenn ich weiß was ich meine
hier klo fazit video mein klo i love water water da ist es ein premium klo und ich sag
euch wie es ist wer einmal ein richtig gutes klo sowas in der richtung daheim hatte der
will nix anderes mehr das klo hat sogar eine fernbedienung mehr wasserdruck weniger wasserdruck
spülung an spülung aus damendusche föhnen absaugeautomatik presets wasser mehr links
wasser mehr links wasser mehr rechts wasser kreisen lassen sprühen temperatur an aus
temperatur hoch temperatur runter exzellent exzellent und so sieht das dann aus guckt
hier so sieht das aus wenn man da draufklickt passt schon wie in japan ja es ist deutsches
klo achtung oh guck mal das zeigt übrigens auch ein wenn die spülflüssigkeit in der
filter leer geht und jetzt max knopf drücken knopf drücken zeigt wie es funktioniert steckdose
im nassbereich ja das klo braucht eine steckdose deswegen müssen das auch das muss von fachpersonal
eingebaut werden das ist so eine das ist so eine rotgelbe steckdose die ist glaube ich
explizit für sowas gedacht gesichtsspoiler ja so drück drauf max drück drauf guck das
ist die düse das ist die düse normalerweise ist da bobbes hier da ist der arsch da wo
hier das da schutz jetzt drauf ist so jetzt fährt die düse aus und spritzt in den bobbes
nicht face league wo ist face league oh hier forehead league ist da guck mal meine stirn
stirn league und dann wasserstrahlende bobbes und das beste ist passt mal auf wenn das fertig
spülen ist guck mal guck mal was passiert wenn das fertig spülen ist dann kommt ein
fön raus und bläst den bobbes ab den fön benutze ich aber normalerweise nicht das mag
ich nicht lass das nur abspülen das ist für mich ein unglaublicher riesen vorteil dass
ich im home office auf mein eigenes klo kacken gehen kann uns mal klar auszudrücken das ist
ein so großes plus das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen ach ja übrigens das hier
ist ein nfc tech rfid wenn ich da das handy dran halte geht die heizung gegenüber an
was auch immer ich jetzt hier noch erzähle keine ahnung aber übrigens die waage hier
unten ist auch per bluetooth per bluetooth an der heim automatisierung angebunden ich
habe jetzt einen graf in meiner heim automatisierung wo es überträgt wie pepo fett ich gerade
bin ich schwiege mich nicht vorne nach dem scheiß nicht wie mich eigentlich einmal morgens
beim zähneputzen nach dem zähneputzt du musst wegen deines klos auch nicht um klopapier
im supermarkt kämpfen das ist wohl wahr aber ich verwende den fön nicht das heißt ich
verwende trotzdem klopapier aber ich habe überhaupt keine klopapier probleme weil dafür
wurde ich geflammt vor 1 2 jahren ja ich habe 6 90 rollen klopapier bestellt vor noch nicht
allzu langer zeit und die sind zum größten teil immer noch
ich habe ich habe das bild das bild von der palette nicht mehr egal ich habe mir eine
palette klopapier bestellt vor zwei jahren oder eineinhalb jahren da wurde ich geflammt
auf twitter nach dem motto max wie kannst du so ein unding machen aber seitdem habe
ich einfach genug klopapier easy und ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum es die leute darüber
überhaupt aufgeregt haben ich meine ich habe bei einem online großhandel klopapier bestellt
vor ist das problem das steht jedem 96 96 rollen 96 rollen ah was ist 20 packungen oder so
ich glaube 20 packungen oder sowas das steht jedem frei online zu einem sanitär großhandel
zu gehen und sich klopapier zu bestellen ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum sich die leute
damals auf twitter so drüber aufgeregt haben aber gut ich meine es ist pepega twitter da
weiß sie es ist ja nicht so als hätte ich irgendjemand das klopapier weggenommen dadurch
dass ich bei dem großhandel bestellt habe oder so die leute sind einfach so rückständig
dass sie denken nur weil es im supermarkt knapp ist oder nur weil es im supermarkt gerade
nichts gibt gibt es keine andere möglichkeiten auf der welt mehr an klopapier zu kommen großhandel
klopapier einfach mal ordentliche menge bestellt gut ist ruhe fertig so viel platz braucht das
nicht 20 packungen oder sind es überhaupt 20 packungen wie viel klopapier rollen sind
in einer packung klopapier rollen pro packung 10 10 stück 8 8 mal 8 sind 64 also 690 durch
8 12 12 packungen habe ich bestellt wie lange hast du drauf gewartet ungefähr zwei wochen
also überhaupt kein problem man muss einfach nur ein bisschen nachdenken aber damit haben
wir es in deutschland generell nicht so wenn man darum geht sachen im internet zu bestellen
da denken ja alle so oh nee gibt es nicht klopapier auch im quelle katalog einfach mal ein bisschen
in modernen zeiten ankommen ins internet gehen und klopapier bestellen gut ist genau
dass die eigentliche knappheit ist daraus entstanden weil ich sie schnell genug zum
supermarkt transportieren konnten ich habe sie im kurs ich habe übrigens hier bestellt
high g high g.de und wenn du da suchst klopapier da findest du massig so viel klopapier kannst
du im leben nicht loswerden was sie hier findest ein paket eine palette 28 ich habe dann habe
ich 14 leute dann habe ich an den moment pakete kate moment es gibt keine also ich habe auf
jeden fall keine 1000 1000 rollen ich habe 96 rollen das gab es als fertige fertige packung
hier das habe ich war statt nähe ich habe 96 ist auch egal ist ja auch egal einfach
im internet bestellen und gut ist das war der tweet ja das war der tweet genau hier guck
mal da kannst du auch als privatperson bestellen ja ich habe ich habe nicht ich habe nix mit
kein kein gewerbedings oder so mich registriert hätte ich machen können aber der bauer war
in dem rechten zentrum ja kommt vor da guck da einfach im online handel bestellt boomer
kennen das internet nicht der hat es richtig erkannt der hat es richtig erkannt die meisten
leute sind einfach zu blöd für da haben sie manche dann wieder übelst rüber aufgeregt
archlinux einsetzt ja beste beste das sollte man machen deine anforderung an die firma
ist ich meine die wollen ja auch immer so viel von einem sagst du leute wir sind uns
einig aber eine sache ist dann auch offen i use arch by the way und ich komme nur zu
euch wenn ich archlinux verwenden kann vielleicht hast du glück es gibt ja durchaus firmen
die sagen freie betriebssystemwahl nee wochenwechsel mag ich nicht ja weil weiß was manchen so
vorschwebt nur im firmeninteresse das finde ich auch geil wenn die immer davon ausgehen
dass man im firmeninteresse immer die sachen im firmeninteresse macht aber die firma nie
in dem anderen also nie in seinem interesse was machen muss wisst ihr wie ich meine so
nach dem motto wie samstags irgendwie sonderwartungsarbeiten ja natürlich da sollen die leute kommen wie
die firma soll die leuten mal entgegenkommen bei irgendwas nee nee nee das machen wir
nicht wenn das so einseitig läuft bin ich dann auch nicht bereit das mehr weiter zu
machen übrigens das ist tatsächlich ein großer vor und auch nachteil bei dieser ganzen
homeoffice geschichte du kannst dich prinzipiell dadurch durch homeoffice dadurch dass es
jetzt eben auch so breit akzeptiert ist an vielen stellen du kannst dich deutschlandweit
wenn nicht sogar international weit bewerben aber umgedreht könnten theoretisch zumindest
die unternehmen die mit der zeit gehen homeoffice anbieten auch bewerber nehmen aus ganz deutschland
aktuell ist es eher ein vorteil für dich weil es einfach an allen stecken an an an
allen stellen händering gesucht wird und ich bin immer noch der meinung es gibt keinen
fachkräftemangel im eigentlichen sinne also wer will bekommt fachkräfte also was was
ich mir gefallen lasse ist wenn jetzt jemand sagt ja es gibt insgesamt ja mehr leute die
die it experten wollen als insgesamt it experten gibt das mag sein da zählen aber auch ganz
viele furchtbar unattraktive arbeitsangebote für stellen zu die die keiner machen will
und im umkehrschluss gibt es auch ganz viele leute die aktuell in irgendeine stelle haben
aber innerlich da eigentlich gar kein bock mehr drauf haben die quasi schon innerlich
gekündigt haben und wenn du den leuten attraktives angebot machst dann kommen die auch generell
wenn du es schaffst den leuten gute arbeitsbedingungen zu bieten und das was sie was sie sich wünschen
dass das ja mal dann kommen die auch zu dir du findest it experten das ist kein problem
was man was heute halt nicht mehr geht ist zu sagen wir sind das geilste unternehmen
auf der welt es wollen doch eh alle zu uns und deswegen müssen wir keine gescheiten
vorteile bieten weil es reicht doch dass wir wir sind das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert
vielleicht wenn du microsoft google oder facebook facebook weniger wenn du microsoft oder google
oder amazon auch nicht aber wenn du microsoft und google bist vielleicht noch ja dann dann
mag das dann mag das funktionieren aber das hat ja auch einen grund die leute wollen ja
nicht die wollen ja nicht einfach nur hin weil es microsoft oder google ist ja eine
spezielle vorstellung davon und die können sich das aussuchen aber nicht die 0815 klitsche
um die ecke und es gibt kein recht darauf dass man sagt ja wir müssen aber wir wollen
ein it experten haben für xy und wir kriegen kein ein recht darauf ist schwachsinn das
ist ganz einfach wenn du die leuten was ordentliches bieten kannst mit guten arbeitsbedingungen
da kommen die auch zu dir ist übrigens nicht nur in der it so ist im pflegebereich oder
im krankenhaus oder sonst wie ist das ganz genauso die wundern sich alle die sagen immer
ha die pflege ist so unattraktiv wir haben einen riesen mangel an pflegekräfte und und
kranken schwester und kranken pflege und alten pflege also das ist so unattraktiv ja wie
wäre es mit besseren arbeitsbedingungen und mehr geld das geht auf gar keinen fall wo
kommt man denn dahin aber die pflege ist so unattraktiv uns fehlen so viele leute das
geht auch gar nicht pf hans pf hans an mehr geld bezahlen bessere arbeitsbedingungen
ne ne das das geht aber auch nicht das ist so widersprüchlich irgendwie das ist komplett
wir die geben sich die antwort doch selbst was sie machen müssen um wieder mehr leute
dahin zu bekommen oder die müssen leute ordentliches gehalt bezahlen und das schlimmste in im pflegebereich
ist noch nicht mal das gehalt sondern die arbeitsbedingungen wären die arbeitsbedingungen
besser wozu auch gehört dass du mehr leute hast für die gleiche anzahl an patienten und
ordentliches gehalt bezahlt dann machen die leute das auch aktuell rennen die leute aus
pflegeberufen und im medizinischen bereich im alten pflegebereich die rennen schreiend
weg die haben da kein dock mehr drauf da denkst du das siehst ja auch schon daran dass die
können wir euch auch dran erinnern wo die leute im krankenhaus applaudiert haben klapper
klapper gemacht haben aus dem fenster ganz ehrlich davon kann sich keiner was kaufen
es ist cool irgendwie so bisschen wertschätzung zu bekommen das motiviert auch aber aber das
wiegt scheiß arbeitsbedingungen und scheiß gehalt nicht auf und die leute rennen halt
dann schreien weg die haben keinen bock ich mein was bleibt als was bleibt als alternativ
wir können uns nordkoreaner holen oder sowas keine ahnung das wird das wird auch anders
nicht machbar sein vor schwierig nachdem du als praktikant ja eigentlich nichts eigenständig
machen kannst ist es schwierig im home office kann ich mir vorstellen auf der anderen seite
wenn du jemand hast der dir aktiv was was zeigt und ich mitmachen lässt und so kann
das durchaus funktionieren könnte ich mir vorstellen keine erfahrung mit
ja ungefähr ungefähr 2000 euro das klo gekostet
heute schon spät ja ja ich dachte ich habe nicht manche leute über mein klubpapier damals
sie bis aufgeregt
habt ihr auch ein ibmz system auf der arbeit ja haben wir
wobei ich weiß es nicht ob es ein ja doch glaub schon die mainframe dinge heißen doch
so ja ja haben wir ich sag was ich mir vorstelle dass ich das vielleicht nicht mit der vorstellung
von einigen chefs deck kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen kannst du mir ein videoschneid
program empfehlen nicht wirklich ich benutze sony vegas das ist aber eigentlich nichts
was man wirklich so aber einfach empfehlen kann erstens viel zu teuer und auch irgendwie
bisschen umständlich da vinci resolve ist voll angesagt weil es kostenlos ist auch ja
ich sehe ich sehe das insofern ähnlich ich kann es nachvollziehen wenn man sagt dass
zum beispiel ein krankenhaus dass das ist nicht mit also mit mit wie sagt man so mit
vollen händen das geld aus dem fenster wirft oder so also das das finde ich schon sinnvoll
dass man grob guckt dass dort nicht komplett unsinnige entscheidungen getroffen werden
in dem krankenhaus ja was kosten nutzen angeht aber im groß und ganzen krankenhäuser sollten
keine unternehmen sein die gewinnorientiert sind wenn das plus minus null oder auch mit
einem leichten minus rausgeht finde ich das voll voll und ganz okay dafür bezahle ich
im endeffekt auch gerne steuern ich habe damit überhaupt keine schmerzen steuer zu bezahlen
ich meine ich weiß ich beschwer mich öfters mal drüber so nach dem motto warum muss ich
bei dem ganzen scheiß so viel steuern bezahlen aber ich habe prinzipiell überhaupt keine
probleme steuern zu bezahlen was mir auf den sack geht ist dass ich nicht den eindruck habe
dass meine steuern im großen und ganzen dort hin fließen was mir persönlich wichtig ist
uns shortcut die video editing unterlinungs man kann auch in blender videos schneiden ja ja das funktioniert habe ich auch letztens mal in dem video gesehen
länder kannst du sogar video texturen haben und sowas dass ein video in einem 3d model dann auf
der seite läuft und länder ist absoluter fallverd shit xxx für den zapp
ok leute schon spät spät ist es es ist richtig spät
oder was der ist schlecht der ist der ist wirklich schlecht
host oder raid wüsste nicht wen der solution ist am stadt fortnight nee kann ich nicht hosten
sorry fortnight sehe ich nicht beides semper video ist am start den haben wir aber auch schon so oft
gehostet in diesem video nur ganz kurz der krieger ist da spielt red dead redemption das juckt mich auch nicht
was opa video was ach semper video wieso ist er so alt schon wie alt ist er denn ich hätte
gedacht dass er eigentlich auch gar nicht so viel älter ist als ich weil ich bin ja auch schon
richtig richtig boomer style ich gehe jetzt einfach auf leute wir sehen uns macht's gut bis denn zu